Rồi các bạn,
buổi hôm qua chúng ta đã xong cái phần
chúng ta
xây dựng à chúng ta huấn luyện cái mô
hình machining dành cho bài toán re của
để chúng ta dùng với cái bộ về điểm của
học sinh đúng không? Điểm của học sinh
chúng ta hết hết chưa nhỉ? Hết rồi.
Check lại nhá.
Đúng rồi, hết rồi đúng không? Chúng ta
đã
chúng ta đã
áp dụng chúng ta dùng search này đúng
chúng ta dùng lazy brick này đúng không?
xong cái project hôm qua thì chúng ta đã
xong được hai project rồi. Một cái là ờ
về bộ diabet là cho bài toán
classification một bộ là cho điểm của
học sinh là cho bài toán rei
toán như vậy.
Thì hôm nay chúng ta sẽ học xong cái
phần mới. Hôm nay chúng ta sẽ học về
Nature Language processing nhá. Mai
chúng ta sẽ học về Nature Language
processing.
À thế thì trong a thông thường ấ trong
khi học trong AI ấ thì cái lộ trình là
như này. Đầu tiên các bạn sẽ thường các
bạn sẽ làm quen với dat và machining.
Thế thì là cái nội dung chúng ta học
trong khóa khóa này đấy đúng không? Thì
khi các bạn làm quen với dat machining,
các bạn sẽ thường các bạn sẽ làm quen
bắt đầu với cái dữ liệu dạng bảng. Dữ
liệu dạng bảng là cái dữ liệu mà chúng
ta sẽ thường hay làm việc cùng nhất. Thế
sau đó thì thường mọi người ta sẽ học
sâu tiếp về deep learning. Trong deep
learning thì nó là cái mảng con của
machining. Chúng ta học ở cái buổi đầu
rồi đúng không? AI mảng to này. Bên
trong có machining, trong nữa có deep
learning. Thế thì deep trong deep
learning ấ thì nó là cái lĩnh vực mà
người ta sử dụng các cái mạng neuron và
những cái biến thể của nó để người ta xử
lý những cái bài toán với những cái rượu
nó phức tạp hơn. Thì những cái rượu phức
tạp hơn này nó sẽ bao gồm hai cái mảng
chính. Một là mảng
computer vision là những cái bài toán
chuyên làm việc với ảnh hoặc là với
video. Thứ hai là NLP là cái trường hợp
chúng ta làm việc với dữ liệu dạng
văn bản, text các thứ. Ngoài ra nó còn
một cái dạng con nữa là dạng audio mà
cái audio thì người ta sẽ ít làm việc
hơn. Audio bây giờ thì từ lúc mà có cái
môn ngốn ngôn ngữ lớn người ta bắt đầu
người ta làm việc nhiều hơn nhưng mà
thường là người ta sẽ dùng cái m ngôn
ngữ lớn chứ còn deep learning về ming
truyền thống người ta gần như người ta
không có làm việc với audio mấy. Thế thì
hôm nay chúng ta sẽ nói một chút về cái
mảng nature langage processing là một
trong hai cái mảng lớn một trong hai cái
mảng con ứng dụng lớn của AI. Xong bài
này chúng ta sẽ buổi sau chúng ta sẽ nói
về computer vision.
Thì Nature Nature Language processing là
cái mảng mà chúng ta các bạn có thể thể
thấy là gì? Là các bạn nhìn trong cái
hình ở bên trái đúng không? Nó là một
cái sự giao thoa giữa chờ chút. Nó là
cái sự giao thoa giữa nhiều nó giữa ba
cái mảng. Thứ nhất là về à về computer
science đúng không? Thứ hai là về AI và
thứ ba là về human language. Nó sự giao
xoa giữa ba cái mảng này. NP là cái mảng
mà nó sẽ liên quan nó sẽ liên quan đến
cái việc là chúng ta ờ nó liên quan đến
sự tương tác giữa máy tính và ngôn ngữ
tự nhiên của con người cả dưới thông
thường dướ dạng văn bản và thi thoảng là
dưới cả dạng giọng nói nữa. Thế thì các
cái các cái thử thách chính trong cái
lĩnh vực xử lý ngự tự nhiên bao gồm cái
gì? Thứ nhất là làm sao để có thể nhận
diện được giọng nói hoặc là chữ viết của
con người đúng không? hiểu được ngôn ngữ
tự nhiên của người và làm sao để có thể
mô phỏng lại ngôn ngữ tự nhiên.
Trong mỗ vài năm trời đây thì cái mảng
này nó rất là bùng nổ nhờ có sự ra đời
giữa ra mắt ra mắt và xuất hiện các mô
hình ngôn ngữ lớn trong một vài năm trở
đây từ cuối 2012 trở đây thì mảng này ch
hot hơn bao giờ hết thế thì các cái ứng
dụng của NP thì nó có rất là nhiều kể cả
trước khi chúng ta có cái sự bùng nổ các
ngôn ngữ lớn thì trong mảng là người ta
đã có rất nhiều những cái bài toán và có
rất nhiều những cái ứng dụng được được
triển khai trong cuộc sống hàng ngày để
có thể giải quyết các cái bài toán khác
nhau. Ví dụ các bạn thấy là ngày xưa
chúng ta có những ứng dụng ví dụ như
kiểu là personal assistant tức là các
cái chữ ly hảo cá nhân ấy đúng không? Ví
dụ như là Siri này đúng không? Quantana
này hoặc là Google Assistant đúng không?
Hoặc là những cái ứng dụng kiểu auto
complete ví dụ như là kiểu tự động điền
từ còn thiếu đấy đúng không? Ví dụ như
là ngày xưa các bạn tìm kiếm trên Google
chẳng hạn đúng không? Các bạn gõ một vài
từ là nó sẽ cho các bạn kết quả sau đúng
không? Những cái từ còn lại. Đấy hoặc là
những cái ứng dụng liên quan đến spell
spell checking tức là kiểm tra lộ trình
tả. Như bạn thấy là hầu như trong những
cái ứng dụng gõ văn bản ví dụ như là
Google Doc hoặc là Microsoft Word thì
bạn thấy là không thiếu gì những công cụ
như này đúng không? Và cuối cùng là
Translation là liên quan đến dịch đại
diện tiêu biểu là Google Translate.
Thế thì ờ với các cái mô hình các cái mô
hình trong NOP ấ ngày xưa thì chúng ta
sẽ chia ra làm ba loại chính với mức độ
phức tạp tăng dần. Đầu tiên là các cái
mô hình dạng là Rubase. Rubase model là
những cái mô hình nó dựa trên quy tắc.
Các cái mô hình này đơn giản là chúng ta
sẽ tự mình chúng ta sẽ định nghĩa ra các
cái quy tắc dựa trên hiểu biết của chúng
ta về ngôn ngữ học. Sau thì máy tính nó
sẽ chỉ đơn giản nó sẽ dựa vào các cái
quy tắc này để nó làm theo. Ví dụ như là
khi mà chúng ta có thể đính cái quy tắc
là gì? Là khi mà có ờ có một cái chuỗi
số có khoảng 8 đến 10 số viết liền nhau
thì đấy khả năng cao đó là số điện thoại
đúng không? Hoặc là các bạn định nghĩa
quy tắc là gì? Là khi một cái từ có cái
chữ cái đầu tiên viết hoa thì đó là tên
riêng, đó là danh từ riêng. Kiểu kiểu
như vậy đúng không? Đấy. Thế thì cái
cách này thì nó đ cái ưu điểm nó rất là
đơn giản và nó rất là trực quan, nó rất
là dễ hiểu, dễ giải thích. Nhưng mà cái
nhược điểm là gì? Nhược điểm là các bạn
thấy là cái ngôn ngữ của con người ấ nó
rất là phức tạp và nó không cố định.
Ngôn ngữ người không cố định. Chúng ta
cứ sau một thời gian chúng ta sẽ đẻ ra
những cái từ mới. Chúng ta phát minh ra
những cái từ mới. Và nhiều khi những cái
từ cũ ấy sau thời gian chúng ta theo
thời gian chúng ta cũng sẽ add thêm
những cái nghĩa mới cho nó đúng không?
Ví dụ cách đây khoảng 20 năm chẳng hạn
thì cách đây khoảng 20 năm thì trong
tiếng Việt chúng ta trà xanh nó chỉ là
một loại đồ uống thôi đúng không? Nhưng
mà bây giờ cái từ trà xanh nó lại có
thêm nghĩa khác rồi đúng không? Bản thân
con người chúng ta, ngôn ngữ chúng ta
chúng ta không bao giờ để nó đứng yên cả
đúng không? Bản thân chúng ta cũng sẽ
liên tục chúng ta phát triển ngôn ngữ để
làm sao chúng ta có những cái từ mới
hoặc là những cái từ cũ có thêm những
cái ý nghĩa mới đúng không? Thế thì khi
mà ngôn ngữ nó phát triển liên tục như
vậy thì nếu chúng ta muốn xây dựng mô
hình theo cái hướng tiếp cận là rase tức
là dựa vào quy tắc ấy thì chúng ta sẽ
phải liên tục lúc nào cũng phải có người
người ta ngồi đấy người ta update người
ta cải thiện người ta modify các thứ
đúng không và điều này nó khiến cho cái
việc là cái khả năng mở rộng của những
mô hình này nó rất là hạn chế tại vì bao
giờ cũng cần phải kèm các người đi cùng
đúng không
đấy là cái loại thứ nhất loại đấy thì
mình không vẽ trên cái hình này cái loại
thứ hai là chúng ta có những cái mô hình
NLP cổ điển nhưng cái mô hình NLP cổ
điển là những mô hình NLP dựa trên các
cái thuật Thật toán machining cổ điển
chúng ta đã học trong những buổi đầu đấy
đúng không? Supor machine forestry K
stable logistic version. Đấy tất cả
những thuật toán này được gọi chung là
machine cổ điển. Đấy thì các cái thậ
toán NB cổ điển là dựa trên những cái mô
hình này. Thế thì các cái hợp này thì
người ta chúng ta sẽ phải có những cái
bước tiền xử lý để làm sao chúng ta có
thể convert dữ liệu dạng văn bản thành
cái dạng mà máy nó có thể hiểu được. Sau
người ta sẽ đưa cái rượu này vào trong
cái cái mô hình machining truyền thống
để nó có thể đưa ra cái dự đoán của
mình. Được chưa? đấy là cách tiếp cận
bình truyền thống. Cái tiện này thì các
cái mô hình này thì nó sẽ khai thác ra
những cái mẫu câu nó có ý nghĩa trong
cái dữ liệu huấn luyện để có thể đưa cái
dự đoán. Được chưa? Thông thường thông
thường cái mô hình này ấ người ta rất
hay dùng nó trong những cái bài toán
liên quan đến phân loại. Phân loại ví dụ
gì? Các bạn sử dụng cái mô hình để làm
sao có thể nhận xem là một cái bài báo
nó về chủ đề văn hóa, thể thao, chính
trị, xã hội hay là âm nhạc. Kiểu kiểu
như vậy. Thế hoặc là cái mô hình để phân
loại xem là cái ý nghĩa cảm xúc của cái
văn bản có nghĩa tích cực hay là tiêu
cực hay là trúng tính. Kiểu kiểu như vậy
thì những cái mô hình kiểu này những cái
mô hình những cái mô hình mô truyền
thống nó rất là phù hợp với những bài
toán đơn giản như vậy.
Loại thứ ba là những cái mô hình deep
learning. Trong cái xu hiện nay thì đây
là cái cái hướng đi nó phổ biến nhất.
Các cái mùi ngôn ngữ lớn nó nằm trong
cái deep learning này nhá. các m lớn hay
là bản thân nó cũng là cái mặc nằm trong
cái deep learning này. Thì theo xu thế
thì đây là những cái hướng hot nhất, có
nhiều ứng dụng nhất, ứng dụng mạnh mẽ
nhất và tạo ra những mô hình nó tốt
nhất. Thì những cái mô hình này có cái
tính khái quát rất là cao và nhìn chung
là nếu chúng ta có đủ số lượng dữ liệu,
tức là chúng ta có đủ có có nhiều dữ
liệu ấy thì các cái mô hình dipenning
này bao giờ nó cũng sẽ vượt trội so với
các cái mô hình machining. Đấy nhưng mà
nó chỉ vượt trội khi nó có thật nhiều dữ
liệu thôi. Đấy deing nó có khả năng mạnh
mẽ hơn với machining. Nó giải quyết được
nhiều bài toán mà machining cổ điển
không có làm được. Và kể cả với những
bài toán mà machineing cổ điển làm được
thì deep learning nếu chúng ta có đủ dữ
liệu và giờ nó cũng sẽ thường nó sẽ có
cái performance nó cao hơn. Thế nhưng mà
cái yêu cầu thì nó không hề dễ dàng một
chút nào. Chúng ta phải có rất nhiều dữ
liệu đúng không? Trong phần lớn trường
hợp nó sẽ dượu chúng ta phải đánh nhãn.
Và cái thứ hai nữa là gì? Thứ hai nữa là
chúng ta sẽ cần phải có tài nguyên phần
cứng đúng không? Chúng ta sẽ phải có tài
nguyên phần cứng thì lúc này chúng ta
mới có thể phân lình ning. Ví dụ các cái
mô hình chúng ta học trong cái khóa này
là những cái mô hình machining nó chỉ có
khoảng vài chục, trăm hoặc là vài nghìn
tham số thôi thì các bạn có thể hoàn
toàn các bạn chuyên trên máy của chúng
ta hoàn toàn bình thường. Nhưng mà với
những cái mô hình ấ chúng ta sẽ nó sẽ có
những mô hình ngày xưa nó chỉ khoảng ví
dụ là vài triệu vài chục triệu tham số
thôi. Còn bây giờ về các cái m ngôn ngữ
lớn nó có đến hàng tỷ hàng chục tỷ tham
số thì để huấn luyện trên mùi này chúng
ta lại cần phần cứng rất là mạnh mẽ thì
chúng ta mới có thể huấn luyện được chứ
còn nếu mà dùng CPU thì phải chờ cả năm
thì mình huấn luyện xong. Được chưa? Đấy
trong ba cái loại này thì cái loại đầu
tiên thì bây giờ người ta rất là ít
dùng. Cái loại thứ hai người ta dùng một
vài trong trường hợp hạn chế còn phần
lớn là người ta sẽ dùng deep learning để
người ta có thể giải quyết các cái bài
toán. Nhưng mà tuy nhiên do cái khóa này
chúng ta học tập trung vào machining thì
chúng ta cũng sẽ thử thử cùng nhau làm
sao chúng ta áp dụng machining để có thể
giải quyết một cái bài toán phân loại
văn bản rất là đơn giản. Và sau khi
chúng ta học xong rồi chúng ta sẽ nói
xem là
vì sao mà các cái thuật toán trong
machining nó vẫn có khả năng giải quyết
các cái bài toán đơn giản trong mảng.
Thế nhưng mà vì sao trong thực tế người
ta gần như là người ta không dùng các
cái tổ toán machining để người ta làm
cái điều này mặc dù nó làm được đúng
không? chúng ta sẽ nói về những cái hạn
chế của nó nhưng mà chúng ta sẽ chỉ có
thể nói về hạn chế khi mà chúng ta thử
làm mà thôi. Được chưa?
Và ngoài ra ấy thì thật ra cái việc mà
học học
NLP trong cái phạm vi của machine nó có
một nó có một cái ưu điểm nữa là gì? Nó
giúp chúng ta hiểu cái cách mà chúng ta
tiền xử lý dữ liệu làm sao để chúng ta
đưa dữ liệu từ cái dạng văn bản là cái
dạng mà chỉ có qua ngư hiểu thôi thành
cái dạng số cả để cho máy có thể hiểu
được. Đây là một bước rất là quan trọng
bởi vì những cái mô hình deing hay là
những cái mô hình ngôn ng lớn sau này
người ta cũng dựa vào cái bước tiền xử
lý này để người ta có thể làm sao giúp
cho mọi người có thể hiểu được dữ liệu
được chưa? Thế trong hôm nay chúng ta sẽ
tập trung vào cách tiếp cận thứ hai là
gì? Chúng ta dùng cái thuật toán
machining truyền thống cổ điển để chúng
ta giải quyết bài toán. Được chưa? Đấy.
Thế thì với cái mảng dù là dù là với dữ
liệu dạng bảng hay là dạng văn bản hay
là dạng âm thanh hay là dạng gì đấy nữa
thì cái bước đầu tiên là chúng ta có vẻ
làm sao để chúng ta tìm cách để chúng ta
có thể giúp cho máy nó có thể hiểu được
ngôn ngữ của con người. Được chưa? Chúng
ta input đầu vào nó là văn bản như này
nhưng mà tất nhiên máy nó không bao giờ
nó hiểu văn bản như này đúng không?
Chúng ta sẽ phải có cách để cho chúng ta
có thể convert những cái văn bản này
thành cái dạng mà máy nó có thể hiểu
được. Thế thì một trong số những cách mà
đơn giản nhất, basic nhất, cổ điền nhất
mà người ta có thể làm là gì? Là người
ta sẽ sử dụng cái thuật toán tên là back
of word. Back of word. Back là cái túi.
Word là từ. Back of word túi của các cái
từ. Cái cách này nó rất là đơn giản
thôi. Đầu tiên chúng ta sẽ có cái văn
bản đầu vào c bên trái các không? I love
this movie các thứ này đúng không? Đây
ta tách đồ vào. Thì bây giờ ấy chúng ta
muốn convert kiểu backward là gì? Chúng
ta sẽ chúng ta sẽ tách cái văn bản này
ra thành các cái từ riêng lẻ. Được chưa?
Chúng ta sẽ tách văn bản này thành các
cái từ riêng lẻ. Sau đó chúng ta sẽ đếm
xem là trong các cái từ này mỗi một từ
nó xuất hiện bao nhiêu lần. Chúng ta sẽ
thống kê nó ra. Được chưa? Nên các bạn
nhìn này. Đúng. Đầu tiên chúng ta có đ
input đồ vào đúng không? Chúng ta tách
lẻ nó ra. Tách lẻ nó ra như này. Sau
chúng ta sẽ sau khi tách lẻ xong và
thành từng từ rồi, chúng ta sẽ đếm xem
là mỗi từ xuất hiện bao nhiêu lần. Ví dụ
các bạn nhìn đây đúng không? Từ xuất
hiện 6 lần này. Từ a xuất hiện lần, từ Z
xuất hiện bốn lần. Từ to xuất hiện ba
lần, từ xuất hiện ba lần vân vân vân
này. Đúng không? Cái backward này nó
cũng giống như kiểu là cái cái back of
word này thì các bạn nhìn này, có một
cái đặc điểm rất là quan trọng của back
of word là gì? Và với back of word ấy
chúng ta sẽ chỉ quan tâm là một từ nó có
xuất hiện hay không và nếu có thì nó
xuất hiện bao nhiêu lần chứ chúng ta
không quan tâm đến việc là nó xuất hiện
ở đâu. Không phải là chúng ta không quan
tâm mà chúng ta có muốn quan tâm cũng
không quan tâm được đúng không? Chúng ta
có muốn quan tâm chúng ta không quan tâm
được. Chúng ta chỉ biết là gì? À cái từ
xuất hiện sáu lần, từ a xuất hiện năm
lần vân vân chứ chúng ta cũng chẳng biết
là nó xuất hiện ở đâu. Đúng không? Đấy,
người ta gọi là back. Tại vì sao? Tại vì
đấy chính là cái tí nhất của cái túi.
Giống kiểu các bạn đi chợ cũng thế. Các
bạn đi chợ thì ví dụ các bạn đi vào
trong siêu thị đúng không? Các bạn có
một cái túi đúng không? Các bạn bỏ đồ
vào thì lúc mà các bạn về nhà ấy, các
bạn lấy đồ từ cái túi đấy ra ấy thì các
bạn cũng sẽ chỉ có thể biết là gì? Là
hôm nay tôi đã mua những cái món đồ gì
và tôi mua số lượng bao nhiêu thôi. Còn
cái món đồ nào tôi mua trước, món đồ nào
tôi mua sau các bạn sẽ không có biết.
Đúng không? Bản nhất của cái túi nó như
thế mà đúng không? Trong cái túi này
chúng ta chỉ biết là chúng ta có những
cái gì thôi, còn cái nào có trước, cái
nào có sau chúng ta hoàn toàn chúng ta
không có biết đúng không? Thế là back of
word.
Thế thì với cái backward này ấy, chúng
ta không giữ được thông tin về mặt vị
trí quế từ. Thế nhưng mà vì sao người ta
vẫn cứ dùng nó? Tại vì trong rất nhiều
các cái bài toán chúng ta chỉ cần biết
là có từ nào xuất hiện và nếu có nó xuất
hiện bao nhiêu lần là đủ để chúng ta để
chúng ta giải quyết bài toán rồi. Chúng
ta không phải lúc nào chúng ta cũng cần
phải có cái vị trí của nó. Ví dụ là gì?
Ví dụ trong một cái bài toán rất là cổ
điển trong NOP đó là bài toán phân loại
văn bản. Các bạn chú ý nhá, trong bất kỳ
một cái mảng nào bài toán phân loại bao
giờ cũng là bài toán cơ bản nhất. Với
dạng bảng các bạn có phân loại gì đấy
đúng không? Ví dụ là trong người bị bệnh
đúng không? Trong bảng NLP các bạn có
bài toán phân loại văn bản document hay
là text classification hoặc trong ảnh
các bạn có bài toán image
classification. Nhưng bài toán phân loại
bao giờ cũng là bài toán cơ bản nhất.
Thế thì
thế thì đối với bài toán phân loại này
ấy à bài toán phân loại văn bản ấy các
bạn nhớ không? Bây giờ giả sử nhá chúng
ta muốn phân loại xem một cái văn bản nó
thu về chủ đề là thể thao chính trị văn
hóa, xã hội hay là học đường nhạ. Ví dụ
như vậy đúng không? Thế thì bây giờ giả
sử các bạn có có một cái bài báo đi đúng
không? Cái bài báo này ấ mà nó có cái từ
Messi với cả Ronaldo chẳng hạn đúng
không? Các bạn chỉ cần biết là cái bài
báo ấy nó có từ Messi với Ronaldo thôi
thì khả năng rất rất cao bài báo này là
về chủ đề thể thao đúng không? Chúng ta
cũng chả cần biết là cái từ Messi nó
xuất hiện ở đâu. Chúng ta cũng chả cần
biết cái từ Ronaldo nó xuất hiện ở đâu.
>> Nhưng một khi mà có hai cái từ này thì
khả năng rất cao là thậ chứ chỉ cần có
một trong hai từ thôi khả năng rất cao
nó là về chủ đề thể thao đúng không?
Hoặc là các bạn
>> có bạn nào có câu hỏi gì à?
Hoặc là nếu mà chúng ta có một cái văn
bản mà nó ờ có từ ví dụ như là Blackpink
hay là BTS chẳng hạn đúng không? Thì khả
năng rất là cao là cái văn bản này nó về
chủ đề âm nhạc đúng không? hoặc là văn
bản nào có cái từ là Donald Trump hoặc
là Joe Biden chẳng hạn thì khả năng rất
là cao. Đây là ờ khả năng rất là cao là
đây là tài liệu về chủ đề
chính trị đúng không? Đấy. Thế thì rõ
ràng là gì? Có rất nhiều bài toán tôi
chỉ cần biết là có cái từ đấy xuất hiện
hay không còn tôi cũng chẳng phải biết
nó ở đâu là tôi cũng đã đủ để tôi giải
quyết bài toán rồi. Thế nên người ta mới
phát minh ra cái cách thể hiện back of
post này đúng không? Nó đơn giản nhưng
nó hiệu quả trong nhiều trường hợp. Được
chưa? Đấy là ý nghĩa của back of words.
Đấy. Thế bây giờ đây là cái trường hợp
mà các bạn chỉ có một cái văn bản thôi.
Nhưng trong thực tế người ta sẽ phải áp
dụng nó với rất là nhiều văn bản. Thế
bây giờ nếu tôi có nhiều văn bản tôi làm
nào? Thì các bạn nhìn đây. Đây là một
cái ví dụ này. Thông thường trong thực
tế mỗi cái văn bản ta đoạn rất là dài
nhưng mà ở đây để cho đơn giản để cho dễ
minh họa thì mình sẽ coi như là cái văn
bản mình nó rất là ngắn thôi. Được chưa?
Thì các bạn nhìn này, đầu tiên nói về
mặt thuật ngữ
thì thông thường chúng ta sẽ có một cái
tập hợp của rất là nhiều những văn bản,
văn bản rất là dài đúng không? Thì cái
tập hợp này người ta sẽ không gọi nó là
ví dụ là list of documents, người ta sẽ
không gọi như vậy, người ta sẽ gọi nó là
một cái corpus. Cpus các bạn hiểu một
cách đơn giản nó là gì? Nó là một tập
hợp của nhiều cái tài liệu thế thôi.
Được chưa? Ở đây mình có một cái copus
này. Thế thì ở trong copus này mình sẽ
có bốn cái tài liệu. Như mình nói rồi,
bình thường tài liệu rất là dài. Nhưng ở
đây mình cho viết ngắn thôi cho nó dễ.
Được chưa? Thế thì bây giờ ấy để có thể
xây dựng cái thể hiện back of word cho
các cái tài liệu này thì việc đầu tiên
chúng ta phải làm là gì? Là chúng ta sẽ
cần phải xây dựng lên một cái vocabulary
x một cái bộ từ vựng. Cái bộ từ vựng này
nó sẽ bao gồm tất cả những cái từ đã
xuất hiện ít nhất một lần trong cái tài
liệu của chúng ta. Được chưa? Những cái
tài liệu xuất hiện ít nhất một lần trong
các tài liệu của chúng ta được chưa? Thế
thế ví dụ đây các bạn thấy không? Mình
xây dựng ngên cái vocabulary này mình sẽ
có có một cái có 22 từ thế này. Được
chưa? có 22 từ thế này. Đây là những cái
từ nóã xuất hiện ít nhất một lần trong
tối thiểu được một cái document đúng
không? Tối thiểu xuất hiện một lần trong
bất kỳ một document nào là đã đủ điều
kiện để rơi vào đây rồi. Được chưa? Thì
khi mình sử dụng này thì mình sẽ thấy là
mình có tổng gọi là 22 từ. 22 từ này
đúng không? Another này, best này, book
này, vân vân vân vân. Được chưa? Sau
bước này bây giờ tôi sang một cái việc
là gì? Là tôi sẽ tôi sẽ số hóa cái tài
liệu của tôi dựa trên cái vocabulary
này. Số hóa bằng cái nào? Thì bây giờ
như này, tôi có bốn tài liệu đúng không?
Tôi có bốn cái documents và cái
vocabulary của tôi tôi có 22 từ. Thì bây
giờ tôi sẽ làm việc là gì? Tôi sẽ tạo ra
một cái ma trận có kích thước là 4 x 22.
4 là số hàng là số lượng documents. 22
là số cột là số lượng từ trong cái
vocabulary của tôi. Được chưa? Sau đó
thì [khịt mũi] bây giờ sẽ điền vào vị
trí của từng ô một. Ở vị trí hàng i cột
j. Ở vị trí hàng I của J nó sẽ thể hiện
là gì? Là trong cái document I nó có bao
nhiêu cái từ J xuất hiện. Được chưa? Nếu
nó không xuất hiện thì tôi ghi là 0. Nó
xuất hiện một lần tôi ghi là 1, xuất
hiện hai lần ghi là 2. Ví dụ các bạn
nhìn ở ở đây nhá. Đúng không? Có vẻ là
cái vị trí này đúng không? Vị trí đầu
tiên này đúng không? Là nó sẽ là
document đầu tiên và cái từ thì rõ ràng
là trong cái document đầu tiên này cái
từ uner ấy nó không không xuất hiện lần
nào nên là tôi cho nó cái số 0. Được
chưa? Bên cạnh nó là từ best. Xong đen
đầu tiên từ best một lần cho vào đây là
1. Được chưa?
Hoặc trường hợp cá biệt là gì? Trong
document thứ ba này tôi có cái từ là one
này. Từ số one nó xuất hiện hai lần đúng
không? Which book you prefer? This one
another one. Được chưa? Từ one sẽ hai
lần số nó là 2. Được chưa? Thế ở đây tôi
chỉ đơn giản là tôi đếm cái tần số nó
xuất hiện thôi đúng không? Tôi đếm cái
tần số dựa trên số lần một cái từ nó
xuất hiện trong một document. Thế thôi.
Thế thì các bạn nhìn này, dựa vào cách
biến đổi back of word này đúng không?
Tôi đã làm được hai việc. Việc thứ nhất
là gì? là tôi số hóa các cái văn bản của
tôi từ dạng text là cái dạng mà con
người hiểu thành dạng số là dạng mà máy
óc nó hiểu là cái thứ nhất. Cái thứ hai
nữa là gì? Là lúc ban đầu của tôi ấ các
cái đoạn tex tôi nó dành ngắn khác nhau
nhưng mà qua cái phép xử lý này tôi sẽ
đưa nó về các cái vecơ có độ giải nó
giống như hiệt nhau. Và đây là điều rất
là quan trọng. Tại vì sao? Các bạn nhớ
là hai cái bài vừa rồi chúng ta thực
hành đúng không? Các cái mô hình trong
machining ấy chúng ta khi chúng ta đưa
rượu vào luyện ấy thì chúng ta đều phải
có cùng kích thước với nhau đúng không?
Ví dụ với cái bộ diabet chúng ta có tám
input đầu vào và một output đầu ra đúng
không? thì input đầu vào nó sẽ luôn là
những vecơ có tám phần tử hoặc là cái bộ
về student score ấy có bảy giá trị đầu
vào và một giá trị đầu ra thì cái input
đầu vào sẽ phải luôn là một vectơ có bảy
phần tử đúng không? Thì input đầu vào
của các cái input à các cái input đầu
vào của chúng ta ấy nó phải kí thức nó
giống y hiện nhau đúng không? Chứ không
thể nào ông dài ông ngắn được đúng
không? Cho nên là tex ban đầu này ông
nhiều từ ông ít từ thì sẽ không đưa vào
mô hình được. Mô hình nó đã không hiểu
các cái từ này rồi mà kể nó có hiểu đi
thì nó cũng không có nhận được khi mà
cái input vào kích thước khác nhau. Đúng
chưa? Đấy là ví dụ của back of word.
Được chưa? Với back of words, chúng ta
chỉ đơn giản chúng ta quan tâm việc là
xem là trong mỗi một cái document có cái
từ gì xuất hiện và nó xuất hiện bao
nhiêu lần. Thế thôi. Được chưa?
Lý thuyết thì là như vậy. Và lúc mà các
bạn code rất là dễ thôi. Tại vì trong sơ
người ta làm hết rồi. Sơn người ta làm
tận chân răng cho các bạn rồi. Các bạn
làm rất là dễ. Cũng giống như kiểu chúng
ta thực hành mấy buổi vừa rồi thôi.
Chúng ta sẽ có một cái class riêng thực
hiện cái việc tính
đếm xem là có từ nào xuất hiện và xuất
hiện bao nhiêu lần. Sau chúng ta cũng sẽ
fit transform với bộ train transform với
bộ test. Cái này thì chúng ta thực hành
sẽ làm cho các bạn nó không khác gì
những gì chúng ta làm buổi hôm qua. Được
chưa? Đấy các bạn nhìn đây đúng không?
Chúng ta cũng dùng cơn. Trong cơn có một
cái class tên là countorizer.
Chúng ta sẽ dùng cái class này chúng ta
có thể chúng ta biến đổi dữ liệu của
chúng ta từ dạng input ban đầu thành cái
dạng cái vecơ như thế này. Được chưa?
Ok. Đến cái bước này các bạn có câu hỏi
gì không?
Đế m bạn câu hỏi gì không? Vẫn đơn giản
đúng không? Vẫn đơn giản đúng không? Thế
thế bây giờ chúng ta sẽ
vecơ hóa chưa hiểu lắm á.
Đây nhá các bạn nhìn đây đúng không? Nó
có hai bước đúng không? Bước đầu tiên là
chúng ta sẽ tạo ra một cái vocabulary.
Cái vocabulary này ấ nó sẽ bao gồm tất
cả những cái từ nào mà xuất hiện tối
thiểu một lần trong bất kỳ một cái tài
liệu nào trong cái corpus này. Được
chưa? Cus là danh sách của các cái tài
liệu của chúng ta. Được chưa? Thì cái
bước đầu tiên tạo vocabuly. Ví dụ ở đây
trong đây chúng ta có một cái vocabulary
có 22 từ. Sau đó chúng ta sẽ tạo ra một
cái ma trận có m hàng n cột. M hàng số
hàng là số lượng tài liệu. N cột số cột
là số lượng từ trong cái vocabulary. Sau
chúng ta sẽ gán cái điểm cho từng cái vị
trí một. Phần tử vị trí hàng I của J nó
sẽ thể hiện là trong cái document I thì
cái từ thứ J này nó xuất hiện bao nhiêu
lần được chưa? 0 1 2 Nếu không xuất hiện
nào thì ghi là 0. Xuất hiện một lần thì
ghi là 1. Xuất hiện hai lần thì ghi là
2. Thế thôi. Được chưa? Sau cái bước này
chúng ta sẽ thứ nhất là chúng ta sẽ số
hóa được tài liệu ban đầu tại thành là
dạng văn bản thành cái dạng vecơ dạng số
mà mọi người có thể mà máy có thể hiểu
được. Và thứ hai nữa là gì? là cái vectơ
này có độ dài cố định. Đây điều rất là
quan trọng tại vì nó phải độ dài cố định
tôi mới đưa được vào trong mô hình
machine learning. Được chưa?
Rồi. Ai có câu hỏi gì nữa không?
Th mắc gì nữa không?
Tiếp nhá. Đấy. Thế thì
bây giờ chúng ta sẽ nói qua một chút về
cái Fly các cái bước để chúng ta có thể
tiền xí dữ liệu, dữ liệu dạng văn bản
hay là hình ảnh hay là âm thanh hay là
bảng ấy thì chúng ta sẽ luôn cần phải
tiền xử lý để chúng ta có thể đưa vào mô
hình một cách nó tốt hơn, nó hiệu quả
hơn và nó hợp lệ. Được chưa? Thế thế thì
với dượng dạng văn bản ấ chúng ta cũng
có những cái bước tiền xử lý được chưa?
Thế đây là một cái pip điển hình của các
cái bước tiền xử lý văn bản.
Thì đầu tiên cái bước đầu tiên chúng ta
sẽ có bước đó là bước chúng ta sẽ ta gọi
là remove punctuation. Punctuation là
cái gì? Ptuation là những cái dấu câu.
Được chưa? Puation dấu câu. Vì sao người
ta lại muốn loại bỏ dấu câu? Vì thông
thường trong cái văn bản ấy thì dấu câu
là cái thứ thường nó mang lại ít ý
nghĩa. Thông thường dấu câu chỉ dùng để
phân phân phân cách thôi. Dấu câu rất ít
thể hiện một cái ý nghĩa gì đấy. Thế nên
là bây giờ nếu ta không loại bỏ ấy thì
mặc định thì thì những cái dấu câu này
cũng sẽ được cho vào trong cái vocabuly
này. Thế nên là bây giờ ta bỏ dấu câu đi
để cho nó giảm mất kích thước đi và tay.
Anyway thì cái dấu câu nó cũng có ít
mang lại ý nghĩa mà được chưa? Tất nhiên
bảo là ít được ảnh nghĩa thì cũng không
hẳn tại vì thật ra là cũng có những cái
dấu câu mà nó không chỉ là nhiệm vụ tách
câu đâu mà nó còn làm nhiệm vụ là để
giúp chúng ta có thể nó mang cái ý nghĩa
gì đấy. Ví dụ như là các bạn thấy là
các bạn thấy là ví dụ như là dấu hỏi
chấm chẳng hạn. Dấu hỏi chấm thường có ý
nghĩa là câu hỏi đúng không? Câu truy
vấn. Còn dấu chấm than thường nó có ý
nghĩa là kiểu cảm thán đúng không? Thì
thật ra bảo là cái dấu câu nó không có
không có ý nghĩa gì hoàn toàn cũng không
hẳn. Thế nhưng mà thường ý nghĩa nó rất
là ít đúng không? Gần như các cái dấu
câu thường nó chả ý nghĩa gì ngoài cái
việc là nó phân tách câu. Thế nên người
ta sẽ loại bỏ đi. Đến bước đầu tiên.
Bước thứ hai là bước lower case à lower
text. Lower text có nghĩa là gì? Th
chúng ta sẽ đưa các cái chữ viết hoa
thành viết thường đúng không? Hoa thành
viết thường. Tại vì thường chữ viết hoa
thường nó chỉ có hai trường hợp là một
nó là đầu câu và hai nó là tên riêng.
Nhưng mà thật ra thì nếu mà chúng ta để
nguyên viết hoa như vậy ấ thì ví dụ cái
từ go từ go viết hoa vết t viết thường
này thì nó sẽ rơi vào hai cái vị trí
khác nhau. Trong khi là thật ra là ý
nghĩa nó chả khác gì nhau cả. Được chưa?
Thế nên là người ta sẽ đưa về chưa biết
thường về bước thứ hai. Bước thứ ba là
tocation. Bước thứ ba là tocanization.
Bước số ba này là cái bước mà chúng ta
sẽ bắt đầu chúng ta sẽ split cái văn bản
chúng ta thành các cái thông thường thì
người ta sẽ split thành các cái các cái
từ. Đây cái dạng phổ biến nhất. Nhưng mà
tuy nhiên người ta cũng sẽ có trường hợp
là ví dụ ta sẽ thành những câu đấy hoặc
là những cái đơn vị khác nữa. Thế nhưng
mà cái bước này người ta gọi chung là
word toenization wordation bước số ba
chúng ta văn bản th riêng thành những
cái thành những cái từ riêng được chưa?
Thế bước thứ tư là loại bỏ stopw remove
stopw stopw là những cái từ gì? Stop
word là những cái từ nó xuất hiện rất là
nhiều trong văn bản nhưng mà thường nó
mang lại ít ý nghĩa hoặc nó cần nó chả
mang lại ý nghĩa gì cả. Thì stopw nó bao
gồm những từ rất là phổ biến. Ví dụ có
những cái đại từ nhân xưng I, we he này
đúng không? Những cái mạo từ này đúng
những cái cảm thán từ các thứ đúng
không? Thì đấy là những cái stock word.
Stop word nếu mà các bạn không bỏ đi thì
trong nó sẽ chiếm một cái lượng nhất
định trong cái vocaby khi là ý nghĩa nó
chả có mấy đúng không? Stop word là
những từ nó không mang lại nhiều ý nghĩa
đúng không? IU nó chỉ nhân xưng thôi mà
đúng không? Thế hoặc là nó cũng chỉ là
nó cái ngữ tháp của người ta như thế
thôi. Ta nó chả mang lại ý nghĩa gì cả.
Được chưa? Gần như là không mạ lại ý
nghĩa. Đấy. Bước số bốn.
Thế bước số 5ă các bạn nhìn này. Bước số
năm ấy là cái bước mà nó sẽ có hai
option. Cái bước số 5ă ấy thì như này
các bạn tưởng tượng là ví dụ trong tiếng
Anh nhá đúng không? Danh từ chúng ta sẽ
có danh từ số ít, danh từ số nhiều hoặc
là các bạn có động từ đi. Động từ các
bạn có dạng nguyên thể này, dạng id này
đúng không? Dạng verb in này. Đấy rồi
cùng cái từ nó có thể biến thành danh
từ, trạng từ, tính từ vân vân đúng
không? Thế ví dụ như là từ send. Từ sen
này gọi nó có thể có là hình thái khác
là sense với là sending đúng không? Ý
nghĩa nó giống yệt nhau nó chỉ khác mỗi
là cái hình thái của nó thôi. Thì bây
giờ nếu mà để nguyên như vậy thì nó sẽ
khiến cho cái kích thước của vocabul nó
rất là lớn. Do người ta sẽ làm cái việc
là gì? Người ta sẽ lấy gốc của từ hay
người ta gọi là stemming đúng không? Lấy
gốc của từ. Stem là cái gốc mà gốc cây á
đúng không? Thế thì khi mà lấy gốc của
từ này chúng ta sẽ đưa các cái từ này về
các cái dạng nguyên thể của nó. Dạng
nguyên thể của nó. Thì lấy gốc này người
ta sẽ có hai cách. Cái cách đầu tiên là
cách mà dễ hơn thì thường ta sẽ dựa vào
những cái ru cố định. chung người ta có
những cái rule là nếu tử tôi có cái đuôi
này tôi sẽ bỏ cái đuôi này đi. Được
chưa? Thì cái kiểu này người ta gọi là
stemming. Đúng cái tên lấy gốc luôn.
Standing là cái rất là đơn giản và gần
như là ngôn ngữ nào nó cũng có thể áp
dụng được. Thế nhưng mà cái nhược điểm
là gì? Là do nó dựa vào những cái quy
tắc cố định nên nó có khả năng sẽ tạo ra
những cái từ mà nó không xuất hiện bao
giờ. Ví dụ này learning thành learn,
cool thành cool này. Machine thành cái
machine bỏ đi chữ e. Được chưa? Machine
thành machine bỏ đi chữ E này.
Thì rõ ràng các bạn thấy là nó ưu điểm
nó đản nhưng mà nhược điểm là gì? Nó tạo
ra cái từ nó không nó không tồn tại đúng
không? Cái từ machine nó không chữ e nó
không tồn tại được chưa? Đây cách đầu
tiên. Cách này thì gần như ngôn ngữ nào
cũng là có thể áp dụng được đúng không?
Cái cách thứ hai thì nó là phiên bản
premium hơn một chút là gì? Bây gi tôi
sẽ có một cái kỹ thuật gọi là
lamization.
Lionation ấ thì nó mục đích nó cũng
giống như là scaming theo gì để tôi có
thể map các cái từ khác nhau. Các cái từ
có hình dạng khác nhau thành về cùng một
từ. Thế nhưng mà
thế nhưng mà cái ưu điểm hơn của Lion là
gì? Là nó sẽ luôn đảm bảo là nó sẽ tạo
ra các cái từ nó có nghĩa nhá. Nó sẽ
luôn đảm bảo nó sẽ tạo ra các cái từ có
nghĩa. Để làm được điều như vậy thì cái
lion này thì với mỗi một ngôn ngữ người
ta sẽ cần phải có những người chuyên gia
về ngôn ngữ đó. người ta tạo ra những
cái quy tắc để chúng ta có thể trích
xuất những cái từ mà đảm bảo nó vẫn đảm
bảo là cái gốc nó có ý nghĩa được chưa
thì với lation các bạn sẽ không mọi đạo
cái từ nó nửa mùa thế này được chưa đây
là cái truy hình bao gồm năm bước thế
này
năm bước này thế thì năm bước này ấy đây
là năm bước tổng quát có những ngôn ngữ
mà nó không có đủ năm bước này có những
ngôn ngữ thì ở cái bước này nó lại khó
hơn ngôn ngữ khác có những ngôn ngữ bước
này lại dễ hơn ngôn ngữ khác ngôn ngữ nó
sẽ những đặc điểm khác nhau quy hình
chung là năm bước như này nhưng mà không
phải ngôn ngữ nào cũng có đủ cả năm.
Được chưa? Thế mình lấy ví dụ nhá. Thử
lấy ví dụ này. Theo các bạn này, có ngôn
ngữ nào mà chúng ta không cần cái bước
một không?
Có ngôn ngữ nào mà theo các bạn là nó
không cần bước một không các bạn?
Ngôn ngữ nào không cần bước một các bạn?
Bước một ngôn ngữ nào không cần?
Tiếng Trung không không có dấu câu á.
Ừ. [hắng giọng] Mình theo mình biết thì
cũng ừ theo mình biết là chả ngôn ngữ
nào không cái bước này ngôn nào cũng có.
Được chưa? Bước một thì ngôn ngữ nào
theo mình biết là ngôn ngữ nào cũng cần.
Bước thứ hai là lower case. Lower case
text là viết chữ hoành viết thường. Ngôn
ngữ nào không có cái bước số hai này?
Ngôn ngữ nào không có bước số hai? Từ tự
hình tự hình thì không có đúng không?
Trung Hàn, Nhật không có đúng không?
Bước số ba. Theo các bạn có ngôn ngữ nào
nó sẽ khó với các cái ngôn ngữ khó hơn
ngôn ngữ khác? Ví dụ lấy tiếng Anh là
tiêu chuẩn đi. Theo các bạn có ngôn ngữ
nào nó sẽ khó hơn tiếng Anh ở cái bước
số 3 này?
Chung nhật ấy. Vì sao? Vì sao các bạn
nghĩ cái bước này nó khó hơn? Chúc nhật
mỗi một từ nó đứng riêng lẻ mà tách ra
thì cũng đơn giản thôi, có gì đâu.
À tiếng Việt chúng ta khó hơn đúng.
Tiếng Việt là một ứng cử viên mà nó khó
hơn so với tiếng Anh. Lý do là vì sao?
Vì sao tiếng Việt lại khó hơn tiếng Anh?
Trong khi tiếng Việt chúng ta cũng là
tiếng cũng là dựa trên chữ lain mà đúng
không? Tiếng Việt cũng là chữ Latinh.
Thì vì sao tiếng Việt lại khó hơn tiếng
Anh? Không phải có dấu. Vấn đề không
phải có dấu. Không phải có dấu. Dấu
không phải vấn đề. Dấu nó đi cùng cái từ
này luôn. Tách thì đi dấu đi cùng luôn.
Có cái gì khó đâu.
Tiếng Việt khó hơn không phải do cái
việc có dấu.
Không từ có nhiều nghĩa ngôn ngữ nào chả
có. Tiếng Anh cũng có từ nhiều nghĩa mà
cùng cái từ bank vừa có nghĩa là ngân
hàng vừa nghĩa là bờ sông. Đồng âm khác
nghĩa thì thiếu gì đâu.
À đúng rồi. Từ ghép. Từ ghép mà vấn đề
đúng không? Tướng Việt chúng ta có từ
ghép ví dụ là xanh ánh xanh mơn mở đúng
không? Thì bây giờ có từ ghép. Nếu mà
tách riêng thành những cái từ riêng lẻ
thì nó chả có ý nghĩa là nghĩa nó biến
dạng hoàn toàn đúng không? Thế với về
với về với tiếng Việt nó khó hơn. Còn
tiếng Anh thì thường là mỗi một từ đứng
dương lẻ nó cũng đ ý nghĩa gì đấy rồi
đúng không? Đấy đây bước số ba.
Bước số 4 thì theo các bạn có ngôn ngữ
nào không có?
Bước số 4 ngôn ngữ nào không có?
Bước số 4, ngôn ngữ nào không có?
Ừ. Theo mình biết chả ngôn ngữ nào đúng
không? Tứ Việt mình th những cái từ gì
nhỉ? Tao tớ mày. Tứng Việt mình là nhiều
thằng khác. Tao tớ mày, cậu ấy đúng
không? Dạ vâng. Thường thường cái từ này
nó chả có ý nghĩa gì cả đúng không? Đấy,
bước số năm là một bước mà nó khó với
rất nhiều ngôn ngữ nhưng cũng có những
cái ngôn ngữ bước cũng có những cái nước
mà mà cái bước này thì
rất là đơn giản, thậm chí là không có
luôn. Nước nào không có bước số năm hả
các bạn?
Ngôn ngữ nào không có bước số 5?
Ngôn ngữ nào không có bước số 5 các bạn?
Đúng rồi. Tựng Việt chúng ta. Thông
thường bước số năm là cái bước rất là
khó đặc biệt là về cái lamization. Tại
vì là muốn sử cái lation này phải có
hiểu biết về ngôn ngữ đó thì mới xây
dựng được. Nhưng rất may chúng ta làm
tiếng Việt chúng lại không có. Từng Việt
chúng ta hoàn toàn không có bước số năm
này. Đúng không? Hôm qua tôi ăn, hôm nay
tôi ăn, ngày mai tôi sẽ ăn thì vẫn là
cái từ ăn đấy. Đúng không? Tôi mua một
quyển sách, tôi mua hai quyển sách, tôi
mua ba quyển sách thì vẫn là từ quyển
sách đấy. Nó không khác gì cả đúng
không? Chúng ta khó hơn khác ở bước số
ba nhưng mà cái bước số năm chúng ta nhẹ
gánh. Được chưa? Đấy.
Thì tất nhiên những cái bước này chúng
ta làm chúng ta sẽ không làm thủ công.
Làm thủ công thì mệt lắm đúng không?
Chúng ta phải dùng thư viện. Thế bây giờ
mình sẽ giới các bạn một vài những cái
thư viện làm việc cả với tiếng Anh và
với tiếng Việt nhá. Đầu tiên là chúng ta
sẽ ưu tiên international trước, tiếng
Anh trước. Được chưa? Thế thì với tiếng
Anh ấy những cái bước này các bạn nhìn
này trong thư viện CON ấy thư viện CON
chúng ta học trong mấy buổi vừa rồi ấy
thư viện Sơn thì nó cũng có nó cũng có
offer một vài những cái function một vài
những cái hàm để có thể làm những bước
này. Thế nhưng mà cái thư viện Sơn đây
ấy nó là thư viện chuyên biệt là về dat
và machining. Thế mạnh của nó là về data
machining chứ thế mạnh của nó không phải
là là
NP. Thế nên là nó cũng không cung cấp
quá nhiều những cái hàm dành cho xử lý
tiền xử lý NP đâu đúng không? Thì do đó
người ta cần có những cái thư viện khác.
Thế thì một trong số những cái thư viện
rất là nổi tiếng một trong số những cái
thư viện rất là nổi tiếng để dùng để
tiền xí dữ liệu đó là thư viện có tên
không tiền xí dữ liệu đ văn bản nó tên
là NLTK.
NTK là một thư viện quốc dân dành cho xử
lý cái bài toán liên quan đến [âm nhạc]
bảng NLP. Được chưa? Natural language
thư bên này nó cũng cấp rất nhiều những
cái công cụ những cái hàm để chúng ta có
thể làm việc với dựa đoạn văn bản đấy.
Vô cùng dễ dàng ví dụ nhá. Cái này cài
rất là đơn giản. Cài thì dễ thôi. Cài
thì đây cho các bạn xem cài cực kỳ dễ
hình nhá.
Đây ví dụ nhá. Ví dụ nhá.
Scrip mới nhá. Đúng không? NP test nhá.
Được chưa? Bây giờ muốn dùng cái thư
viện này chúng ta phải cài trước. Cài
rất là dễ này. Pip này. Cách install,
cách NLTK là xong. Đây nhá. Bạn chờ load
xong mình cài cho các bạn xem này. Đây
nhá. Pip này. Cách install này. NT này.
Xong. Máy mình hình như có rồi. Mình cài
lại xem.
Có rồi được chưa? Có rồi này. Có rồi
được chưa? Có rồi. Đấy. Thế bây giờ dùng
rất là dễ. Ví dụ nhá các bạn nhìn này.
Nó có cái word này được chưa? Ví dụ
import nhá.
Tôi cũng chẳng copy gì đây nó nó làm sẵn
chúng ta đây này đây ví dụ đây nhá.
Đấy đúng ví dụ như này được chưa? Bây
mình dùng là output này đúng không? Bằng
NLTK này word này được chưa? Win output
này
đây được chưa? Nhìn thử nhá.
Lần đầu chạy nó hơi lâu chứ bình thường
cái này nó chạy nó nó chạy nhanh lắm.
Tại vì máy mình lần đầu chạy bao giờ
cũng hơi lâu một chút
nhá. Chúng ta cứ ngồi chờ một chút. Tại
vì máy mình mình mới khởi động cái
report à mình mới khởi động cái cửa sổ
này nên là nó hơi chậm nhá. Đấy. Đấy là
ví dụ đấy là nó liên quan làation được
chưa? Thế ngoài ngoài cái good toation
này thế là cái này rất là đơn giản chúng
ta các bạn code thay thủ công thì các
bạn cũng làm được thôi đúng không? Nhưng
mà ngoài ra nó có rất nhiều công cụ khác
nữa. Ví dụ là gì? Ví dụ trong NLP nó có
một cái khái niệm gọi là part of speech
POS nhá các bạn. Đây này. P of speed
này. P of speed có nghĩa là gì? Tức là
chúng ta sẽ chỉ ra là từng cái từ ấy nó
thuộc cái loại gì? Nó là động từ, tính
từ, trạng từ, danh từ. Đây này. Thông
thường các bạn nhìn đây này. Có những
loại như này. Đấy. Danh từ nhá, đại từ
nhá, động từ nhá, tính từ nhá, trạng từ
nhá, giới từ nhá, liên từ nhá và thán từ
nhá. Được chưa? Thế thế bây giờ các bạn
nhìn này. Đây ví dụ đây. S là gì? Là
giới từ đúng không? Cái này chắc là danh
từ số đếm này đúng không? Tính
tính từ à? Adjective
là cái gì nhỉ? Chả biết cái gì gì nó là
cái gì. Giới từ này đúng không? Danh từ
chỉ thời gian này đúng không? Danh từ
chỉ ngày đúng không? Danh từ chỉ danh từ
chung chung. Được chưa? Đấy cái này gọi
là part of speed được chưa các bạn? Mà
các bạn không dùng đây đây các bạn nhớ
cái NTK này được chưa? Đấy word tách
riêng ra được chưa?
Cái này mà các bạn áp dụng vào tiếng
Việt nó sẽ sai đấy. Tiếng Việt thì nó
tiếng Việt thì nó cứ dựa vào khoảng
trắng thôi. Tiếng Việt kiểu gì nó cũng
sai. Ví dụ là à ờ
ví dụ là à hai
ví dụ nhá.
Hai
đường thẳng song song. Ví dụ như vậy
đúng không? Ốc thử tiếng Việt vào nhá.
Các bạn thấy được chưa? Đây này. Tiếng
Việt kiểu gì cũng sai. Được chưa? Tách
riêng ra được chưa? Đấy.
Thế speed này nó còn nhiều cái lắm. Ví
dụ nó còn có một cái nữa là các bạn có
thể các bạn lấy gốc của từ. Các bạn nhìn
nhá. Cái lấy gốc của từ. Vậy mình nói
các bạn đã có hai cái option đúng không?
Một là stemming và hai là lamization
đúng không? Nhìn thử nhá.
Stammer nhá.
Đây các bạn nhìn nhá. Cái stemmer này.
Smer nhá. Đúng không? Cái này nó gọi là
porter stammer được chưa? Cái từ gốc ban
đầu đây. Được chưa? Ví dụ đây là toàn
cái danh từ số nhiều này các bạn nhìn
này. Nó các bạn khi bạn lấy gốc này. Lấy
gốc một cái ph đơn giản nó chỉ bỏ những
cái từ cuối thôi nhưng mà bỏ như vậy nó
sẽ ra cái từ chả có ý nghĩa gì. Ví dụ
đây từ flies. Và đây cái từ fly này. Từ
này nghĩa gì các bạn? Tiếng Việt mình
nghĩa gì các bạn? Flies nghĩa là gì?
Danh từ nó là cái gì đây?
Nghĩa là gì đây?
FL là cái gì đấy? Con ruồi đúng không
những? Những con ruồi đúng không? Đưa
thành số làm gì có từ nào như này đâu
đúng không? Hoặc là deny đúng không?
Deny ID đúng den nó cũng đâu có ý nghĩa
gì đâu đúng không? Hoặc là gì? Hoặc là
cái từ
chonizer đúng không? Kẻ thực dân đúng
không? Làm gì có từ nào như thế này đâu
đúng không? Có lần có nhưng mà ý nghĩa
nó không phải có luôn là cái dấu
cái dấu dấu dấu dấu dấu hai chấm đấy
đúng không? Nhưng mà hai từ này nó có
liên quan gì nhau đâu đâu. Hai đây không
phải là đây không phải là cái gốc đúng
của cái từ này đúng không? Hoặc là cái
từ
đây các bạn nghĩ từ agree này từ agree
giống đâu đúng không? Agree này nó bỏ
đuôi id đi các bạn có thể là mỗi thành
như này thôi được chưa? Không có ổn được
chưa? Đây là cái lamization à đây là cái
cái stamming thì nó chỉ như này thôi.
Thế cái thứ hai là cái cái cao cấp hơn
thì nó là lamization. Lionation nó sẽ
cao cấp hơn. Các bạn chờ một chút mình
tìm nó ở đâu nhở? Đây là gì ấy nhỉ?
Nó gọi cái gì nhở? Mình không nhớ tên
lắm. Chờ tí nào.
Lizer
cái gì ấy nhỉ? À đây rồi đây này đây đây
nhá nhìn này thấy không từ dog thành dog
này đúng ch đúng không cái nhà thờ đúng
không chả biết nó là cái gì đây đúng
không đấy thấy chưa cái leation này thì
bao giờ nó cũng nó cũng vip pro hơn
nhưng mà th xử lý nó sẽ lâu hơn một
chút. Và thứ hai nữa là không phải ngôn
ngữ nào cũng có cái này. Những ngôn ngữ
nào nó phải tương đối phổ biến. Có nhiều
người quan tâm thì nó mới có cái này
thôi. Còn những ngôn ngữ nó ít phổ biến
ví dụ như kiểu là Somali chẳng hạn thì
khả năng cao là không có cái này. Được
chưa? Do đó thì thông thường ấ khi mà
người ta sử dụng cái bước số 5ă ấy thì
nếu mà đó là cái ngôn ngữ nó nếu nó là
cái ngôn ngữ mà nó tương đối phổ biến
người ta sẽ gọi người ta sẽ dùng cái
lation còn nếu đế ngôn ngữ mà ít phổ
biến người ta sẽ dùng stemming. Được
chưa?
Rồi cái đấy là đấy là cái thư viện đầu
tiên. Đây là thư viện quốc dân nó còn có
nhiều thứ lắm. Cái thư viện này có rất
nhiều thứ. Cái hồi ngày xưa cái hồi 2010
2016 2017 ấ mình đi làm mình làm working
student cho một công ty công ty mình hồi
chiều này khuế làm về rượu dạng văn bản
này với mạng NLP này thì dùng thên này
cực kỳ nhiều luôn nó giúp các bạn tiền
sĩ cực kỳ hữu hữu ích luôn mỗi tội nó
chỉ có một cái ngôn ngữ ngôn ngữ linh
thôi thì nó hỗ trợ được thế thứ hai thư
viện này thì có thể với những bạn mới
các bạn sẽ dùng nhìn nó sẽ hơi bị nhìn
nó hơi bị nhiều thứ quá thì có chúng ta
có một vài th viện đơn giản hơn nhất là
ví dụ như là textop.
Đây một thực hiện rất rất là hay, rất là
đơn giản thôi. CF đây. Text block như
này. Được chưa? Simplify tex text
processing này. Đúng không? Nó cũng có
những cái thứ đây ví dụ đây các bạn nhìn
này. Đây này. Tag này đúng không? Cái
part of speed này đúng không? Danh từ ờ
mạo từ đúng không? Tính từ này. Danh từ
này, giới từ này. Được chưa? Thế ờ các
bạn cũng thể các bạn
các bạn tách nó ra. Tách ra nhiều lắm
đây nhá. Ví dụ là part of speed nhá. Đây
part of speed cái mình vừa mới nói này
đúng không? Từng cái từ nó là cái gì
đấy. Vị trí các thứ thế này được chưa?
Hoặc là cái gì nữa hoặc là hoặc là đây
này. Tocation đây này. Toine này đây to
đây. Tách ra này. Được chưa? Tách ra
này. Được chưa? Đây tách ra tách ra
thành từng word gọi là word to conction.
Đây tách ra thành sentence là sentence
to connection. Được chưa? Thế đây lion
lấy gốc của từ ở đây đúng không? Tôi
muốn đưa về dạng số ít này, số nhiều này
đúng không? Lấy dạng lấy gốc của từ này.
Otover là con a con bạch tuồng nh đúng
không?
Được chưa? Như này nó rất là dễ dùng.
Còn cái gì nữa không? Lion
list speculation cũng ok đúng không?
Speculation đúng không? I have đúng
không? Have này được chưa? Project này.
Fability này. Falibility ở đây. Dou
number l ở đây. Được chưa? Rồi được
chưa? Đây th viện thứ hai th này dùng nó
đơn giản hơn nó ít nó ít hạ hàm hơn là
NLTK. Thế nên là dùng các bạn thấy dùng
nó sẽ dễ hơn, dễ làm quen hơn, dễ làm
quen hơn. Thư viện thứ ba là spacy. Spa
cũng là một thư viện rất là hay. Thì vậy
là thư viện mà nó sẽ
nó cũng tương đối dễ làm quen. Đây các
bạn nhìn nó cũng có những cái đơn giản
ví dụ như là này à lấy góc của từ đây
này. Lation này đúng không? tách tách từ
ra nó hỗ trợ khá là nhiều ngôn ngữ ngôn
ngữ khá không biết có tiếng Việt ở đây
không bà 3000 star rồi đấy th này dùng
cũng ok được chưa đây đ những tiêu việ
tiếng anh nếu mà các bạn làm việc về
tiếng Anh thì các bạn dùng này là ok mới
mình recommend là bạn nào các bạn các
bạn không có nhu cầu các bạn phải đi sâu
vào cái bảng này các bạn muốn dùng nhanh
dùng dễ thì các bạn dùng text pro với cả
spac còn nếu các bạn muốn làm cái chuyên
nghiệp các bạn muốn đi sâu về cái mảng
này các bạn dùng được chưa đấy
Rồi các bạn trước khi sang tiếng Việt có
ai có câu hỏi gì không?
Trước khi sang tiếng Việt có câu hỏi gì
không?
Tiếp nhá. Thế cái tiếng Việt thì như
mình vừa demo cho các bạn xem đúng
không? Các bạn mà dùng cái thực viện này
mà các bạn ốp vào tiếng Việt thì kiểu gì
nó cũng sai. Đây cái này kiểu gì nó cũng
sai đúng không? Rồi các bạn tìm cái part
of speed nó cũng sẽ không có ra đâu. Tại
vì tiếng Anh làm gì có mấy cái từ này
đâu đúng không? Thì bây giờ ấy với tiếng
Việt ấy chúng ta sẽ có một ngày xưa thời
của mình là nó không có bây giờ nó có
mình thư viện hay lắm. Một là cái thư
viện quốc dân do thư viện là under the
sea.
Đây thư viện vô cùng nổi tiếng dành cho
bảng
NLP của dành cho tiếng Việt đây nhá. Các
bạn có thể vào các bạn ủng hộ người Việt
các bạn cho chúng ta một cái star vào
đây nhá. Star vào đây. Đấy.
Under the sea. Under the sea. Cụ này rất
là hay các bạn nhìn nhá. Ví dụ đây à các
bạn chưa cần phải dùng cái agent đâu.
Cái agent này cho cái tác vụ mới rồi các
bạn nhá. Ví dụ ở đây mình có
ơ nhìn nó khác nhỉ.
Ví dụ kia đâu hết rồi
đây các bạn nhìn đây ví dụ đây nhá. Đây
các bạn có cái từ này trang trí quản trị
khởi nghiệm từ nấm so đúng không các bạn
mà dùng tiếng Anh kiểu gì nó cũng sai.
Tiếng Anh kiểu gì nó cũng thành chàng
một từ trai một từ mà đúng không? Chàng
trai này 9x này quản trị khởi nghiệm từ
nấm sỏ được chưa?
Nấm sỏ thách ra này có hợp lý không nhỉ?
Thôi ra biết thế nhá. Tiếp này đúng
không? Rồi cái
đúng không? Sẽ sẽ có cái part of speed
nữa. P of speed đây này.
P of speed nó đổi giao diện gì khác nhỉ?
Đây
đây nhá các bạn nhìn nhá.
Cent đây. T thành từng câu này được
chưa?
Tách chuẩn hóa. Chuẩn hóa tức là gì? Tức
tếng Việt mình nó có dấu câu đúng không?
Có thể người nước ngoài họ viết nhầm vị
trí của dấu đúng không? Thì ví dụ đây
đúng không? Dấu này đúng không? Nghiệm
khóa học đây các bạn âm dấu của nó nó để
sai chỗ này đúng không? Thì đây đây
chuẩn hóa này. Được chưa?
Tiếng Việt mình có quy tắc gì cái dấu
này không nhở? Học lâu quá rồi. Hay là
nó nằm ở giữa nhở đúng không? Đảm này
bảo này đúng không? Nó là
nguyên âm đúng không? Nguyên âm ở giữa
đúng không nhỉ? học lâu quá cũng chả nhớ
nữa.
Thông thường người Việt chúng ta ít để ý
này thì chúng ta có có mấy ai sai đâu
đúng không? Nhưng mà người nước ngoài có
để là bài báo viết rằng ai thìể nó đặt
sai sai chỗ đúng không? Thì chúng ta
chuẩn hóa nó được chưa? Rồi cái gì đây?
Conversion đúng không? Rồi taging đây
nào.
À không vẫn chưa chưa chưa đây. B of
speed đây đúng không? Chợ là danh từ
thịt là danh từ. Chó là danh từ. Nổi
tiếng là tính từ ở là giới từ. Sài Gòn
là danh từ chỉ địa điểm bị là động từ.
Truy quét là động từ. Cái này mà dùng
tiếng Anh khả năng cao nó cũng không làm
được. Tại vì sao? Trong tiếng Anh thì
không bao giờ có chuyện là hai động từ
nguyên thể đứng cạnh nhau cả, đúng
không? Tiếng Anh không bao giờ có chuyện
hai động từ nguyên thể đứng cạnh nhau,
đúng không? Cái này dùng các bạn mà dùng
bằng tư viện tiếng Anh ấ có khi nó còn
chả biết đây là động từ cơ đúng không?
Trang kinh chia nhỏ racy cái thứ này.
Gì nữa? Classification người ta đã huấn
luyện sẵn rất nhiều dữ liệu trên rất
nhiều dữ liệu lớn rồi nên là các bạn có
thể các bạn dùng nó để classify đây này
chia thành các cái chủ đề khác nhau chưa
thể thao kinh doanh infestate này được
chưa
rồi xem al này đúng không nghĩa tích cực
hay tiêu cực này tiêu cực này được chưa
tích cực đây được chưa cực tích cực này
bây giờ cái đây khoảng khoảng nửa năm
thì đây người ta bắt đầu tích hợp cả mấy
cái liên quan đến open rồi đây nhưng mà
thật Và muốn tích hợp này thì các bạn
còn nhiều thư viện khác chứ cũng chả cần
phải vào trong này các bạn làm. Các bạn
dùng thẳng Open AI các bạn dùng các bạn
dùng dùng ngay cái Facebook của Open AI
là cũng xong rồi cũng chả cần phải lộ
vào tận đây để làm thế này. Được chưa?
Phát hiện ngôn ngữ đây tiếng Việt này
cho translation đây các bạn chú này các
bạn dùng translation này các bạn cũng
không phải tốn tiền API các bạn không
cần phải dùng Google Translate gì nên
các bạn cứ dùng thẳng luôn đúng không?
Dùng thẳng luôn được chưa?
T speed nó sẽ cái này các bạn phải cài
cả cái tức là nó sẽ convert cái văn
input là văn bản thành một cái đoạn nói
được chưa? Speed này
rồi được chưa? Thế đây là thư viện dành
cho người Việt của tiếng Việt được chưa?
Bây giờ cài thử nhá giản thử này người
ta làm sẵn đây đúng không? Đ chế độ khoa
học này đây đạn này ví dụ mình dùng thử
nhá dùng thử cái Word toer nhá đâu nhở?
Đây đúng không? Under se
chưa có rồi.
Pip install under the c enter
được chưa?
Cắm nó trời đây đúng không?
What đây
cha
gì ấ nhỉ?
Được chưa?
Xem chạy như nào nhỉ?
Ngoài cái thư viện này ra ấy còn có một
vài thư viện nữa nhưng mà đây là thư
viện nổi tiếng và được sử dụng rộng rãi
nhất nhá. Dự sử dụng rộng rãi nhất. Mấy
thư viện khác thì mình đã thử rồi. Dụ
chắc nó không cao bằng cái này. Cái này
độ xác khá là cao.
Lâu thế nhỉ? Mình này lâu thế nhở.
Được chưa? Thế thôi. Đấy các bạn có thể
các bạn cho người ta một cái star được
chưa? Mình cho vào đây rồi đồ của người
Việt được chưa? Thế thôi đây trên cái
thư viện nó giúp các bạn làm việc với
mảng lâu thế nhỉ. Đây được chưa? Hai
đường thẳng song song đúng không? Mình
thường nó chạy nhanh thô nó không lâu
này. Không biết vì sao lại lâu này nhá.
Được chưa? Thành nhật tiếng Việt
rồi. Ok. Đấy đây là nói qua về chút là
cái đoạn chúng ta liên quan đến tiền xử
lý thôi. Chúng ta phải tiền xử lý đểm
xem chúng ta đưa rượu về cái dạng nó
thuất lợi hơn cho mô hình đúng không?
Không chỉ có việc là chúng ta convert dữ
liệu từ dạng văn bản thành dạng số mà
chúng ta làm sao chúng ta đưa về cái
dạng nó thuận lợi hơn. Chúng ta loại bỏ
những thứ dư thừa đi đúng không? Chúng
ta làm sao chúng ta loại bỏ từ dư thừa
tránh cái việc là cùng một từ nhưng mà
nhiều hình thức nó lại tạo thành những
cái từ khác nhau để nó thu nhỏ phạm vi
của mô hình đi. Được chưa? Đấy
rồi các bạn về cái đoạn này có ai có câu
hỏi gì không?
Có ai có câu hỏi gì không?
Tiếp nhá. Tiếp nhá. Thế
thế thì các bạn nhìn này, vừa rồi ấ
chúng ta nói về back of word đúng không?
Back of words thì bây giờ cái back of
word này thì ưu điểm nó rất là đơn giản,
làm rất là dễ nhưng mà cái nhược điểm là
gì? Là nó bị mất thông tin về mặt thứ
tự. Thông tin về mặt thứ tự thì vừa nãy
mình có nói các bạn là gì? Là có rất
nhiều những cái bài toán, có những cái
bài toán đơn giản mà chúng ta cũng không
cần phải biết thứ tự các cái từ cho biết
là nó xuất bao nhiêu lần, nó có xuất
hiện hay không là đã đủ rồi đúng không?
Nhưng mà tuy nhiên nó sẽ có những cái
trường hợp mà khi mà các bạn không có
thông tin về mặt thứ tự các bạn sẽ khiến
cho mình nó rất là khó khăn trong việc
nó phân biệt các cái input với nhau. Ví
dụ ở đây các bạn nhìn nhá. Ví dụ ở đây
mình có ba cái văn bản như thế này.
Trong nó thì mình đã thực hiện đủ hai
bước đúng không? Bước đầu tiên là tạo ra
vocabulary. Bước thứ hai là chúng ta sử
backward vector. Nhưng mà ở đây với cái
bước vocabulary mình sẽ loại bỏ cả các
cái stopw đúng không? Cái từ là this is
này, a này, I này, win này, đúng không?
Những cái từ nó chả mang lại ý nghĩa gì
cả thì người ta sẽ bỏ đi đúng không?
Chúng ta chỉ còn cái vocabary bao gồm
năm từ là could này, job này, not này,
ignore này với cả tech. Được chưa? Thế
các bạn nhìn này. Thế ngoại trừ cái
document cuối cùng đi thì các bạn thấy
hai document đầu tiên rõ ràng là về mặt
ý nghĩa chúng nó hoàn toàn trái ngược
nhau đúng không? Ý nghĩa chúng nó hoàn
toàn trái ngược nhau. Nhưng khi ở đây
chúng ta đưa với dạng back of word này
thì nó lại ra những vectơ giống y hệt
nhau. Hai vectơ giống y nhau chả khác gì
nhau cả đúng không?
Đấy. Thế bây giờ theo các bạn trong
trường hợp này theo các bạn bây giờ
chúng ta đúng không? Làm như này nó sẽ
có một cái vấn đề là gì? Là bây giờ giả
sử các bạn xây dựng một cái mô hình, các
bạn muốn xây dựng và huấn luyện một cái
mô hình để làm sao có thể phân loại xem
là một cái phân loại xem là một cái
document đầu vào ấy nó có ý nghĩa là
positive hay là negative đúng không? Thì
rõ ràng là hai document đầu tiên này ý
nghĩa nó là nó trái ngược nhau. Nhưng
bây giờ mình đưa vào mình mà số hóa này
lại thành cái vectơ giống yên nhau đúng
không? Rõ ràng chúng nó khác nhau nhưng
mà số nó lại thành vecơ giống y hệt
nhau. Được chưa?
Thế thì bây giờ tôi muốn làm sao để tôi
có thể phân biệt được hai cái document
này. Theo các bạn tôi có cách nào?
Bây giờ tôi dùng back of word này thành
hai vectơ giống y nhau thì bây giờ tĩa
mô hình nó không thể phân biệt được hai
ông này với nhau tại vì ra cùng cái
output mà ra cùng một vectơ. Thế bây giờ
muốn phân biệt chúng thì làm thế nào bây
giờ? Theo các bạn
làm thế nào mới được?
Làm nào?
Theo các bạn làm thế nào? Bây giờ cứ để
nguyên này đúng không? Hai cái từ hai
cái document giống khác biệt nhau hoàn
toàn mẹ ra cùng một vectơ này thì sao mô
hình nó phân biệt được ông này với ông
nào được? Thì muốn giúp mô hình phân
biệt được thì làm thế nào? Bây giờ
có một cách rất là đơn giản là gì? Là
bây giờ lúc chúng ta tách ra ấy, thay vì
chúng ta tách từng từ riêng lẻ, chúng ta
sẽ tách thành những cái tổ hợp hai từ
hoặc là ba từ. Được chưa? Cách này người
ta gọi là grrams. Được chưa?
Thì cái số n ấy nó sẽ thể hiện là chúng
ta muốn dùng bao nhiêu từ liên tiếp nhau
được chưa? Nếu chiều đầu tiên là n bằ n
= 1 thì nó không khác gì vec word cả.
Trường hợp này n = 1 chúng ta gọi là
unigram. Unigram các bạn thấy ví dụ
chúng ta có input input đồ vào là gì?
This is big data AI book đúng không? Đây
là một cái input đồ vào. Thì bây giờ khi
chúng ta dùng cái
chúng ta dùng cái b=ng 1 này thì nó sẽ
ra unigram đúng không? This là một từ,
is là một từ, big là một từ, data là một
từ, ai một từ là một book là một từ.
Được chưa? Thế còn n = 2 thì các bạn
thấy là gì? N bằng 2 thì người ta sẽ gọi
là byground. Byground thì cứ hai từ liên
tiếp thành một cái từ thế này đúng
không? Bây giờ người ta sẽ không gọi lại
từ nữa nhá. Ở đây người ta sẽ không gọi
lại từ gọi từ khác người ta gọi là
token. This is là một token. In là một
token đúng không? Tức là gì? Trong
trường hợp mà unigram thì token là một
từ nhưng trong thì token nó là hai từ
liên tiếp đúng không? Còn với trường hợp
n = 3 là sẽ là ba từ liên tiếp. Được
chưa? Thế các bạn chú ý này, n mà càng
tăng ấy thì cái ưu điểm là gì? ưu điểm
là nó sẽ giúp các bạn có thể dư lại được
càng nhiều cái thông tin mà thứ tự các
từ thờ đi trước thờ đi sau. Thế nhưng mà
nhược điểm là gì? Nhược điểm là nó sẽ
thứ nhất là nó sẽ khiến cho nó sẽ tạo ra
những cái token mà rất là khó có khả
năng xuất hiện lại. Khó khả năng xuất
hiện lại tức là gì? Tức là ví dụ bây giờ
chúng ta dùng unigram đúng không? Toàn
những cái từ đơn lẻ này. Thì cái từ này
nó có thể nó xuất hiện đi xuất hiện lại
nhiều lần và chúng ta khi nó xuất hiện
nhiều lần như vậy chúng ta có thể dựa
vào nó chúng ta biết xem là cái từ cái
nào mà hay có cái những từ này thì nó sẽ
thuộc về cái chủ đề gì. Được chưa?
Thế nhưng mà bây giờ ấy khi mà chúng ta
tăng n lên ấ ví dụ chúng cái từ là es
data ấy cái từ này nó rất là khó xuất
hiện lại. Nhiều khi trong cả nghìn
document nó chỉ xuất hiện đúng một lần
thôi. Thì khi mà chúng ta tạo ra ra
những cái tư những cái token mà nó xuất
hiện đúng một lần như vậy thì rất là khó
để có thể dựa vào nó để biết là ông này
với ông kia nó khác nhau như thế nào
đúng không? Rất là khó để có thể dựa vào
nó để biết được xem là cái chủ đề của
cái to nó là cái gì. Được chưa? Đấy n =
1 = 2 = 3 người ta là unigram bagram cả.
n b= 4 trở lên người ta dùng số thôi
giống như kiểu trong tiếng Anh ấy đúng
không? First, second, third. So từ số 4
trở lên là đánh dùng số bình thường
thôi.
For gram, f gram các thứ. Được chưa?
Thông thường trong thực tế người ta sẽ
không bao giờ người ta dùng n quá. N lớn
nhất là ta dùng 5 thôi. Được chưa? Và
thông thường trong thực tế người ta sẽ
không dùng một loại đơn lẻ mà người ta
sẽ kết hợp nhiều loại ví dụ gì người ta
kết hợp là unigram với là uniby với cả
try hoặc là có thể nhiều hơn. Thế ví dụ
trong này các bạn thấy những cái mô hình
ngôn ngữ lớn người ta sẽ dùng kết hợp n
từ 1 cho đến 5 luôn. Được chưa?
Đấy. Và các bạn chú ý nhá ở đây ấ chúng
ta đã học về NLP cổ điển thì một token ở
đây trong các cái trường hợp nó có thể
là một từ dương lẻ, hai từ dương lẻ hoặc
là ba từ dương lẻ. Dương lẻ nhưng mà đây
là nó liên tiếp nhau đúng không? Một từ
dương lẻ này, hai từ liên tiếp, ba từ
liên tiếp nhưng mà sau này ấ chúng ta
học về các cái mô hình ngôn ngũi lớn ấy,
các cái ngôi ngũi lớn ấy cái token nó
định nghĩa nó khác. Token các bạn hiểu
cách đơn giản gì? Toen là đơn vị nguyên
tử để tạo ra một cái input. Đơn vị
nguyên tử nó là cái gì? Tùy chúng ta
định nghĩa. Đơn vị nguyên tử có thể một
từ, hai từ hoặc là ba từ. Được chưa? Thế
thì trong các cái mô hình ngôn ngữ lớn
ấy, tốc cần nó phức tạp hơn. Tác cần
trong ngôn ngữ lớn ấy thì nó có thể là
một từ, nó có thể là một đoạn của một
từ, tức là nó có thể là nửa đầu của một
từ, nửa cuối của từ, thậm chí nó có thể
là nửa cuối của từ này kết hợp với nửa
đầu của từ kia. Đấy nó có thể nó kết hợp
kiểu như vậy.
Đấy. Thế nhưng mà ở đây chúng ta đang
dùng đang làm việc với machining cổ điển
thì rất là đơn giản thôi đúng không?
Chúng ta tùy cách định nghĩa nó có thể
là một từ, hai từ hoặc là ba từ. Được
chưa? Đấy n mà càng lớn thì chúng ta sẽ
giữ lại càng nhiều thông tin ý nghĩa
nhưng mà nó sẽ làm phình to cái
vocabulary lên và nó sẽ khiến cho việc
những cái từ những cái background vagram
ấy nó xuất hiện lại rất là khó. Được
chưa?
Muốn áp dụng cái này thì trong se rất là
dễ thôi ha. Cũng vẫn dùng cái caporizer
đế nhưng mà trong này nó sẽ có thêm một
cái tham số. Đến hôm buổi tới cho thực
hành chúng ta sẽ dùng chan này.
Tại vì thế này với ấy các bạn hiểu là
cái ngôn ngữ nó rất là phức tạp thành
ngôn ngữ của chúng ta ấy ờ con người
chúng ta viết được thành từng từng thành
từng từ nhưng mà nhưng mà với em góc
nhìn nó lại khác. Tại vì sao? Góc nhìn
ví dụ một từ nhá đúng không? Nó có một
từ ví dụ một từ doing đi đúng không? Thì
cái từ là cái từ speaking đi thì cái
đoạn speak ấy nó thể hiện cái hành vi
đúng không? Cái từ speaking ấy, cái từ
speak thể hiện hành vi nhưng cái từ in
ấy lại thể hiện là cái thời điểm cái
hành vi nó diễn ra đúng không? Tôi đang
nói đúng không? Speaking là đang nói
đúng không? Cái từ speak nó thể hiện một
cái ý nghĩa là cái hành động còn cái
đuôi in thể hiện ý nghĩa là cái thời
gian. Và đây là rõ ràng là đ hai cái
thông tin khác nhau đúng không? Sau đó
thì người ta tách riêng ra để thành làm
sao mỗi cái nó cover một cái ý nghĩa
đúng không? Cách mà máy móc nó nhìn ngôn
ngữ ấy khác với con người nên chúng ta
không ốp cách con người để chúng ta ốp
vào máy được. Được chưa?
Rồi.
Rồi được chưa? Thế bây giờ chúng ta muốn
áp dụng trong s lần cũng rất là dễ thôi.
Rất là dễ thôi. Các bạn nhìn đây đúng
không? Bình thường chúng ta có chúng ta
sẽ có một thêm một cái tham số là range.
Tham số này đến lúc chúng ta thực hành
sẽ nói rõ hơn. Nhưng mà đây các bạn nhìn
qua một chút nhá. Bên này nó sẽ có hai
giá trị, một là cận dưới và hai là cận
trên. Cận dưới, cận trên này có ý nghĩa
là gì? Cận dưới tức là cái số nhỏ nhất
của n là bằng bao nhiêu? Và cận trên là
cái số lớn nhất của n bằng bao nhiêu? Ví
dụ đây là 1 2 thì có nghĩa là nó chạy từ
1 đến 2 thôi. Tức là nó dùng unigram với
cả by chưa? Unigram kết hợp với by chưa?
Stop word tôi sẽ loại bỏ những cái từ
trong tiếng Anh. Sit learn thì nó chỉ có
đúng một cái bộ stopw này thôi. Tức là
các bạn chỉ có thể loại bỏ tiếng Anh
thôi. Còn tiếng khác nó không có. Tiếng
khác các bạn phải tự truyền vào. Được
chưa? Thế đến buổi sau cho tự hành mình
sẽ nói rõ hơn cái phần này. Được chưa?
Ờ đây các bạn nhìn cái vocabuly đúng
không? Vocabuly bây giờ n rằng 1 2 t gì
nó bao gồm cả uni cả bế bao gồm cả một
từ riêng lẻ này. Hai từ riêng lẻ 1 2
đúng không? Kích thước nó sẽ lớn hơn.
Được chưa? Rồi
rồi các bạn đến đây có ai có câu hỏi gì
không?
Đến đây có ai có câu hỏi gì không?
Ok
chúng ta nghỉ giải lam 5 phút các bạn
nhá. 5 phút nhá.
Báo một tí nhá. Bạn nào bạn muốn hỏi thì
các bạn cứ hỏi nhá. Mình vẫn ngồi trên
máy mình nghe thôi nhá.
Mình hỏi tí lớp mình có bạn nào đang học
có bạn nào là sinh viên đang học ở Vin
không nhỉ? Lớp mình có nào là sinh viên
đang học ở Vin không? Vin Uni á.
H
được ok sẽ t Việt thì cũng không có
nhiều nhưng mà ok có một quyển chưa nọ
mình chỉ cho các bạn quyển machining
cơ bản của anh Vũ khệp chà đây
mình không nhớ lớp nào mình chia sẻ lớp
này hay lớp khác bàn
quyền này hôm nọ mình share các bạn chưa
nhỉ
nh hôm nọ nói lớp này hay là lớp Chưa
qu này mình thấy chưa các bạn? Quyển à
bạn chờ tí đây qu này mình chia các bạn
chưa? Rồi đúng không? Nó lớp mình đúng
không? Nó mình nói lớp mình đúng không?
Ừ thập đến rồi. Đây là một quyển nhá.
Quyển thứ hai nữa là quyển à ờ quyển này
thì là quyển đầy đủ nhất rồi. Thật ra
thì đọc sách ấy các bạn đọc đừng lấy số
lượng đọc lấy chất lượng quyển này. Chắ
nếu mà tiếng Việt thì mình thấy là quyển
này là quyển nhất. Thế còn nếu quyển nữa
thì mình chỉ biết quyển về deep learning
thì có tiếng Anh. Còn machining nếu mà
các bạn đọc đọc tiếng Anh thì có nhiều
machining thì ví dụ như là
gì nhỉ?
Quên rồi.
Maching của tiếng Anh
nó không hẳn là đây các bạn chờ đấy nhá.
mình ạ.
Chờ tìm lại cái tên nữ
có một quyền đây. Quyển này cũng khá là
ok. À nếu mà quyển dành cho học đơn giản
thì các bạn thấy có quyển này cũng khá
là ok này.
Khá là ok này. Như này quyển này không
không phải mua đâu. Nhìn thế này thôi.
Như này thôi không phải mua đâu. Này nó
có đâu rồi?
Nó phi đây. Nó phi này. Này đấy đây. Đâu
ấy nhỉ? Đây các bạn click vào đây nhá.
Đây cái vần chương này. Đấy đọc vào đây
được.
Thật ra ấy nếu mà học machining ấy tốt
nhất thì nó có ba quyển nhưng ba quyển
này nó rất là hàn lâm mà mình giới thiệu
các bạn. Mình sợ là các bạn sẽ không đọc
đâu. Ngày xưa hồi mình học về tê môn ấ
tất cả cái môn về maching của mình mình
đều phải học đọc đúng ba quyển này nhưng
mà nó nó rất là nặng rất là hàn lâm.
với các bạn đọc quyển này cho nó dễ nhá.
Quyển này đấy nó trình bày nó rất là rất
là easy. Cái quyển cái quyển machining
của anh Vũ Hữu Tiệp cũng rất là người ta
đơn giản các cái cách khái niệm rồi. Bạn
nào mà các bạn học theo kiểu là học
chương trình chính quy trên trường cao
đẳng đại học ấy, các bạn học kiểu
machine nó sẽ kiểu khác hàn lâm hơn rất
là nhiều.
Không win thì bây giờ các bạn có AI rồi
nó dễ rồi. Các bạn có thể vứt vào trong
AI các bạn bảo nó tóm tắt lược giả các
thứ nó dễ hơn đúng không? Thường ngày
xưa mình không có thì mình phải đọc hết.
Còn bây giờ các bạn có rất là ai nó đơn
giản hóa cho các bạn mà đúng không?
Đó
sách ngày xưa mình chỉ đọc đúng mấy cái
quyển mà trên trường bắt đọc thôi. Mấy
quyển mà mình gửi cho bạn mình cũng chưa
đọc bao giờ cả. Tại vì lúc mà mình biết
đến quy đấy thì mình đã học xong từ rồi.
Rồi ok tiếp nhá. Tiếp nhá.
Rồi các bạn thế bây giờ nhìn này. Nãy
giờ ấy dù chúng ta nói về B of W hay
chúng ta nói về phiên bản cao cấp hơn là
thì thật ra ấy chúng nó cũng chỉ khác
nhau ở cái đoạn là gì? Là chúng ta phân
tách các cái văn bản như thế nào đúng
không? Back of W là các cái từ dương lẻ
đúng không?
Dương lẻ hoặc là hai từ hoặc là ba từ
liên tiếp nhau. Nó chỉ khác nhau đoạn là
phân tách từ như nào thôi. Còn cách mà
gán điểm thì vẫn giống nhau. Chúng ta
vẫn gán điểm dựa trên tần suất xuất hiện
của chúng đúng không? Không lần, một
lần, hai lần, ba lần. Được chưa? Thì bây
giờ cả lớp cho mình hỏi nhá. Được chưa?
Cả lớp cho mình hỏi này. Theo các bạn đi
dù là với backward hay là với thì các
bạn cho mình hỏi này. Bây giờ ấy giả sử
chúng ta xét cái bài toán đơn giản là
bài toán phân loại văn bản. Được chưa?
Phân loại văn bản tức là gì? Chúng ta
muốn làm sao chúng ta có thể lượng cái
mô hình để làm sao nó có thể phân biệt
xem là một cái document đổ vào nó thuộc
về cái topic gì trong ví dụ là chính
trị, thể thao, văn hóa, xã hội vân vân
đúng không? Thế thì bây giờ này thế thì
bây giờ mình muốn là nếu mình muốn sử
dụng một cái mô hình để phân loại đúng
không? Thì bây giờ các bạn cho mình hỏi
này, theo các bạn bây giờ ấy với cái số
điểm các bạn nhìn cái vé các bạn nhìn
cái ma trận ở dưới này được chưa? nhận ở
dưới này. Các bạn cho mình hỏi là thế
bây giờ thế bây giờ ờ
với một cái a ví dụ các bạn đây với một
cái vị trí cụ thểở đây đúng không? Trong
cái document đầu tiên cái từ document
đầu tiên này đúng không? Cái từ số cái
từ số 6 nó có số điểm là 1 từ số 5 nó có
số điểm là 0 đúng không? Thì các bạn cho
mình hỏi này, theo các bạn ấy những cái
số điểm này nó mà cao ấy thì nó sẽ thể
hiện là cái là cái token này à sẽ nói
cái ừ cái token này nó quan trọng trong
cái document này hay là số điểm nó thấp
nó thể hiện nó quan trọng. Theo các bạn
với một token trong một document cụ thể
token nó có thể là một từ, hai từ, ba từ
đúng không? Tùy chúng ta cách chúng ta
phân chia đúng không? Theo các bạn là
trong một document cụ thể thì theo các
bạn là cái điểm của token nó cao thì có
nghĩa là toen này nó quan trọng với
document này hay nó thấp thì nghĩa là nó
nó quan trọng.
cao hay thấp?
Cao quan trọng hay là thấp quan trọng?
Vì sao cao lại quan trọng?
Vì sao nó cao lại quan trọng hả các bạn?
Vì chúng ta làm ăn chúng ta sẽ đọc thì
ta hay gạch chăn keyword là cái từ lập
này nhiều lần nó phản ánh chủ đề của
document. Đầu tiên nhá. Đầu tiên này một
cái token số điểm nó thấp thì tất nhiên
nó không quan trọng rồi đúng không? Thấp
ví dụ thấp nhất là bằng 0. Không tức là
nó không xuất hiện thì làm sao tôi có
thể tôi dựa vào nó để tôi phân loại được
đúng không? Ví dụ một cái trong một cái
document hiện tại một cái token nào đấy
nó xuất hiện không lần thì rõ ràng là
tôi chả dựa nó để tôi phân loại được
đúng không? Thế nhưng số điểm cao thì
như nào? Số điểm cao chúng ta thử nghĩ
một chút nhá. Số điểm cao thử nghĩ một
chút nhá. Nào lớp mình nhiều nam hay là
nhiều nữ hơn nhỉ? Được rồi. Danh sách
lớp đâu rồi?
Đây lớp mình à
lớp mình à nhiều nam hơn. Thế thì hỏi
hỏi hỏi các bạn nam nhá. Lớp mình bạn
nam các bạn nam nào các bạn có vợ và có
người yêu rồi các bạn cho mình số một
đi. Còn bạn nào các bạn đang mùa côi
người yêu không có vợ người yêu có một
mình thôi thì cho mình số 0 nào.
Rồi ok th các bạn thử nhá. Câu này cho
các bạn nam nhá. Các bạn hứ ngồi nghe
nhá.
Thì bây giờ các bạn này, bây giờ hãy giả
sử đi, hãy giả sử lớp chúng ta tất cả
bạn nam chúng ta cỏ lúa bằng nhau tất cả
đều chưa có người yêu chưa có vợ nhá.
Chưa người yêu chưa vợ cỏ lúa bằng nhau
cả lớp bình đẳng đều sinh lờ cả. Được
chưa? Thế bây giờ các bạn tưởng tượng
cho mình nhá. Thế bây giờ giả sử các bạn
đang theo đuổi một bạn nữ đi đúng không?
Các bạn đang theo đuổi một bạn nữ đi
đúng không? Thì bình thường theo đuổi
chúng ta sẽ phải tiếp cận hỏi hai người
ta đúng không? Ví dụ là em ơi ăn cơm
chưa chẳng hạn đúng không? Thế thì các
bạn cho mình hỏi này bình thường nhá
theo kinh nghiệm của mình thì khi mà
tiếp cận một bạn nữ ấy thì ban đầu rất
là khó rất là khó để có cái gì để để có
thể gọi là gọi là gì nhở tức là sao tiếp
cận người ta được đúng không còn rất là
khó thế bây giờ các bạn nhá bây giờ giả
sử này bây giờ giả sử cái đối tượng các
bạn ấy đúng không các bạn à hỏi người ta
người ta cũng niềm nở người ta trả lời
người ta hỏi lại các bạn đúng không các
bạn tặng quà [tiếng cười] người ta cũng
không có cành cao người ta cũng nhận này
các bạn hỏi thăm người ta người ta cũng
trả lời và người ta cũng hỏi thăm lại
các bạn các bạn rủ đi ăn đi chơi người
ta cũng đi đi với các bạn cũng đi ăn đi
chơi xem phim cũng đi cũng đi xem phim
với các bạn đúng không? Tức là mọi thứ
nó rất là ok. Người ta không có cành
cao, người ta không có làm khó các bạn
đúng không? Không làm khó bạn. Đây là
cái điều mà xảy ra nó cực kỳ hiếm theo
kin nhận mình. Đây cái điều rất là hiếm
đúng không? Thì theo các bạn này, theo
các bạn này, theo các bạn khi mà mọi thứ
nó đã tốt như vậy rồi thì theo các bạn
bây giờ nếu các bạn muốn nghĩ xem là tôi
có nên tôi tôi tiến triển tôi gọi là tôi
đường đằng chân tôi lân đằng đầu tức là
tôi tôi tiếp tục hay không thì theo các
bạn là
là ở cái bước này theo các bạn là nếu mà
mọi thứ nó thuận lợi như vậy rồi theo
các bạn là có cái điều gì các bạn cần
phải xem xét hay là cân nhắc hay không
nào?
Nà
chúng ta chúng ta chúng ta
mọi thứ năng ok rồi đúng không? Bây giờ
chúng ta chúng ta chúng ta muốn cân nhắc
xem là chúng ta có nên tiếp tục chúng ta
có nên đẩy tiếp tới hay không đúng
không? triển rồi
cái gì phải cân nhắc không các bạn?
Chứ
các bạn khác thì sao? Sài bên gì nữa rồi
gì nữa?
A
đúng rồi,
phải xem là mình có mỗi mình được như
vậy thôi hay là thằng nào cũng được như
thế đúng không? Ngày xưa mình nhớ cái
hồi mình à sắp tốt được Bách Khoa rồi 54
Bách Khoa rồi 54 Bách Khoa rồi 23 tuổi
rồi mình đi học I ở cái trung tâm đấy
trung tâm tên là Red nó ở ngay chỗ cuối
Bà Triệu ấy
đấy mình hay mình 23 tuổi thì em kia thì
trong lớp có một em rất là xinh rất là
xinh ăn mặc rất là ấy xin body đẹp mọi
thứ ok em mọi thứ rất là ok cái mình một
tuổi mình 33 em thấy 22 em vào lớp thì
lúc đầu mình có ứng cũng sinh thì mình
cũng làm quen các thứ các thứ rủ đi các
thứ Mà à mời đi mời đi cà à mờ mờ mời mờ
mời mời đi ăn chè rồi rồi rồi. Hồi đấy
còn định rủ rủ rủ rủ lên mấy cái chỗ thư
viện để học tiếng Anh nhưng mà có học
cái gì đâu. Toàn ngồi nói chuyện thôi.
Cái này rất là ok. Chat chết các thứ
nhá. Đúng không? Không có cách cành cao
thì mình hỏi câu nào xong là 2 phút sau
đã trả lời ngay rồi. Còn bình thường là
có khi phải cả ngày cơ. Thế
thế là cũng được khoảng 1 tháng. một
tháng xong thì bảo uầi
kèo thế này rồi mà không mà trả lẽ lại
không tiến đúng không? Thế là thế là thế
là ờ
thế là mình mình cứ tiếp tục như vậy
thôi. Sau đấy thì sau đấy thì thì mấy
tháng sau mấy tháng sau tự yên là ờ là
là là có một thằng tự nhiên hôm nó nhắn
tin mình nó bảo ờ ông ơi ông ông ông giữ
khoảng cách với người yêu của tôi nhé.
mình mới biết là ô ô em này có yêu th
chúng nó yêu nhau một năm sừ nữa rồi thế
các bạn thấy không tức là gì
cái điểm nó cao
trên cái document hiện tại đúng không nó
chỉ có ý nghĩa khi mà nó thấp trong
những document khác thôi còn nếu nó cao
mà chỗ nào nó cũng cao ấy đúng không thì
là không ổn rồi đúng không em kia em đấy
chỉ thực sự có ý nghĩa khi mà em đấy nó
chỉ đối nó chỉ nhiệt tình với mình thôi
chứ còn thằng nào nó cũng nhiệt tình thì
thì không ổn đúng không? Tất nhiên nếu
em đấy hoàn toàn không có không có reply
các bạn hoàn toàn nó không có tương tác
với các bạn đúng không điểm bằng 0 thì
không nói đúng không em nếu mà điểm bằng
0 này thì đúng là chả có cái ý nghĩa gì
rồi đúng không nhưng mà điểm cao quá thì
cũng chưa chắc điểm qua thì phải ngó xem
là cái điểm cái token này ấy trong những
document khác ấy nó có cao hay không
đúng không nếu ông nào không cao cả thì
là không ổn rồi đúng không ngoài đời như
nào chúng ta đem vào NP giống y chang
như thế đúng Không, tức là gì? Điểm của
một token trong một document nó mà thấp
thì hiển nhiên nó chả quan trọng rồi.
Nhưng nếu nó cao thì chúng ta cũng phải
xem xem là nó chỉ cao trong cái document
hiện tại thôi hay là chỗ nào nó cũng cao
đúng không? Đóc nào nó cũng cao đúng
không? Ví dụ ví dụ đi ví dụ những cái từ
như là từ Messi với Ronaldo ấy nó cực kỳ
quý giá. Tại vì sao? Tại vì nó chỉ cao
thông thường nó chỉ cao trong các cái
tài liệu về thể thao thôi. Còn những cái
tài liệu về chính trị văn hóa, xã hội
các thứ điểm rất là thấp gần như là
không có. Thì ông này rất là quan trọng.
Tại vì tôi có thể tôi dựa vào ông đây để
tôi phân để tôi nhận diện xem đấy có
phải tài liệu về thể thao hay không. Chứ
còn các cái từ như kiểu là good này,
amazing này, interesting này, những cái
từ này thì tài liệu nào điểm nó cũng cao
cả đúng không? Thì tôi sẽ không thể tôi
dựa vào nó thì tôi có thể phân loại được
ông này với ông kia đúng không? Đấy. Thế
thì cách điểm hiện tại ấy dựa vào tần
suất này ấy, chúng ta sẽ chưa nó không
giúp chúng ta có thể lường trước được
khả năng xem là
cái token này ấ nó phụ nó có phổ biến
trong một loại tài liệu và nó có hiếm
trong các cái loại tài liệu khác hay
không. Đúng, nó chưa giúp ta đánh giá
cái đấy nên chúng ta sẽ cần phải có một
cách đánh giá điểm nó
ưu việt hơn đúng không? Nó ưu việt hơn.
Thế thì trong NP nó có rất nhiều cách
nhưng mà cách thủy tổ cái cách mà gần
như là phổ biến nhất mà cho đến bây giờ
người ta vẫn còn dùng nó gọi là một cái
phương pháp ta gọi đó là
IDF.
TF IDF là viết tắt của term frequencies
inverse document frequency. Được chưa?
Term là các cái chính là các cái token
đấy. Được chưa? Frequency là tần
tần số đúng không? Tần số xuất hiện.
Inverse là nghịch đảo. Document là tài
liệu. Frequency thì vẫn là tài liệu đúng
không? Tức là gì? Tức là tôi bây giờ tôi
sẽ có hai thành phần. Một là frequency
hay tức là TF và hai là inverse document
frequency là IDF. Nhìn nhá. Đúng không?
TF nó cái gì? TF gì? TF.
TF nó bằng cái gì? TF nó bằng là tổng số
lần mà cái token đây nó ghi là Word.
Thật ra các bạn hiểu tổng cắt là toen.
Tại vì sao? Thì không phải lúc nào nó là
unigram có thể nói by. Được chưa? Tổng
số lần mà cái token X này nó xuất hiện
trong document hiện tại chia cho độ dài
của document. Được chưa? Ví dụ cái điểm
TF này của cái từ book trong document
đầu tiên nó bằng là 1/9. Được chưa? This
book is à this is the best book have
ever read. Được chưa? Từ book xuất hiện
một lần trong document này nên là cái tử
số bằng 1. Mẫu số là độ giải document là
bằng 9. Được chưa? Thì các bạn nhìn này,
cái điểm TS này ấy thật ra là cái nó chỉ
khác mỗi cái mẫu số thôi. Còn tử số thì
nó không khác gì cách tính bình thường
này. Cách tính bình thường đây. Đúng
không? Tôi đếm số đầ số xuất hiện này.
Được chưa? Thế các bạn cho mình hỏi này,
theo các bạn cái điểm TS này ấy, cái
điểm TS này, cái mẫu số này nó có ý
nghĩa gì? Nó đóng vai trò gì?
Nó đóng vai trò gì?
Ừ, đúng. Nó chuẩn hóa. Nhưng nó chuẩn
hóa cái gì? Không có nó thì làm sao? có
thế nó nó có cái gì ưu việt hơn là so
với chỉ có mỗi cái tử số đứng chơi choọi
thôi.
Nếu mình chỉ có đúng cái tử số đứng chư
trội thôi thì có thêm mẫu số nó tốt hơn
ở chỗ nào?
Có thế mẫu số tốt hơn ở chỗ nào?
Sẽ độ nháy không? Ừ. Chưa cứ lắm mình so
được các document khác không có mẫu vẫn
so được mà cái mẫu số đây đóng vai trò
gì vì sao tôi lại phải chia s số xuất
hiện chia cho tổng độ dài cái document
đấy vì sao
cùng quy chiếu gì
nào có hỏi có thể mình làm sao cái giải
thích nào để ai cũng hiểu được không nào
đánh giá mất đầ độ quan trọng một cách
tương đối không bị bios
Hàn tâm quá nhỉ. Nào có bạn nào thấy
được cái ý nghĩa của cái mẫu của cái TF
này nó có đóng vai trò gì không?
Đấy thật đơn giản thật dễ hiểu không
nào.
Đây không phải xác suất. Đây là thực sự
rồi. Không phải xác suất nữa. Đây là
thực sự rồi. Nó là tần số nó thực sự
đấy. Xác suất là có thể có thể không
đúng không? Xác suất là một cái giá trị
là khoảng bao nhiêu? Đây là thực sự mà.
Nào, cái mẫu đóng vai trò gì? Sao tôi
lại phải chia cho tổng số lượng từ của
document này?
Vì sao?
Sao
có thể cái mẫu này nó có cái gì nó ưu
việt hơn so với cách đếm truyền thống
tính toán mật độ thực tế của từ này.
Mình nghĩ là có nhiều bạn hiểu đúng
nhưng mà cách giả nó cứ làm sao nhỉ?
Số đánh công bằng cái thể động khác
nhau.
Ừ. Cái tiếp này chưa so ai với ai cả.
Cái tiếp này nó nó nó mới là chỉ một
mình nó thôi. So so với nhau là phải cái
ông dưới cơ. Cái ông IDF cơ mới là cái
ông so với nhau. DF này chỉ một mình nó
thôi đúng không? Tử số cũng là document
này. Mẫu số cũng là document này. Nó
chưa động gì đến ông khác cả.
Ông có vai trò gì?
Nào, rất đơn giản thôi.
Cùng cái từ đấy xuất hiện n lần chẳng
hạn đúng không? Nó xuất hiện trong một
cái tài liệu ngắn thì tầm quan trọng của
nó sẽ phải lớn hơn. Nó chuyện trong tài
liệu dài đúng không? cùng là cái từ đấy
xuất hiện một lần nhưng nó xuất hiện một
lần trong document dài 10 từ thì tầm
quan trọng của nó nó phải quan trọng hơn
là nó xuất hiện một lần trong do có 100
từ đúng không? Cùng là các bạn cái lời
nói của các bạn cái tiếng nói các bạn
trong nhóm có năm người nó sẽ quan trọng
hơn lời nói của các bạn trong nhóm có 50
người có đúng không? Cùng là xuất hiện
một lần cùng xuất hiện hai lần nhưng
xuất hiện một lần hai lần trong document
ngắn thì tầm quan trọng của nó nó phải
hơn là trong document dài đúng không?
một cái mẫu này để tôi đ lúc trước tôi
chỉ đếm cho tôi nó xuất hiện là xuất
hiện mấy lần đúng không? Nhưng mà xuất
hiện mấy lần thì nó lại có vấn đề là gì?
Xuất hiện cùng là một lần nhưng xuất
hiện một lần trong tài điệm nó chỉ có
năm từ với xuất hiện một lần trong tài
liệu 50 từ nó khác nhau đúng không? Cách
đếm trước nó chưa có làm được điều đấy
đúng chưa? Cách này chúng ta mới làm
được cái điều đấy đúng không? Đây là ý
nghĩa của TF. Cái TF này ấy các bạn sẽ
phải tính cho từng token trong từng
document được chưa? Ví dụ cái document
này các bạn có các bạn ở đây các bạn có
bốn document các bạn có 22 token này thì
các bạn phải tính 88 lần được chưa 4 x 2
bằng 88 được chưa t phải tính cho từng
token trong từng document một tiếp cái
tip này cái ý nghĩa của nó là gì nó thể
hiện cái việc là
đúng không tần số xuất hiện của một một
từ trong một một token trong một
document đã được đã được normal cho
chuẩn hóa bởi cái độ dài. Được chưa?
Thành phần thứ hai là IDF. IDF nó bằng
cái gì? F nó bằng logarit câu số 2. Thật
ra ở đây logarit câu số mấy cũng được
nhưng mà đây người ta dùng câu số 2. Các
bạn dùng loga cơ số 10 hoặc là logar
neppe đều được. Được chưa? Logarit cơ số
2 của cái gì? Của một cái phân số. Cái
phân số này tử số là cái gì? Tử số là
tổng số lượng document trong purpus. Tức
là các bạn có bao nhiêu document đấy.
Được chưa? Mẫu số là cái gì? Mẫu số là
số lượng document mà
có chứa cái token x này. Được chưa? Các
bạn chú ý nhá.
IDF bằng logarit cơ số 2 của một cái
phân số với tử số là tổng số lượng
document trong copus có trong copus và
mẫu số là tổng số độ document mà nó có
chứa cái từ chứa cái tốc x này được
chưa?
Thế thì
cái IDS này ấy các bạn, cái ids này ấ
cho mỗi một token các bạn chỉ tính nó
duyên một lần thôi. Tại vì cái điểm IDF
của cùng một token trong tất cả các cái
document là giống y hệt nhau. Các bạn
nhìn mà xem cái tử số nó là tổng số
document. Mẫu số là số lượng document có
chứ cái tử này đúng không? Thì tôi chỉ
tính cho một lần thôi. Tôi sẽ tính nó sẽ
được áp dụng cho tất cả document. Được
chưa? Thì cái IDF này ấ nó sẽ thổi th nó
sẽ đánh ra cái mức độ phổ biến hay là
hiếm của một toen trong toàn bộ các cái
document này. Được chưa? Thế tử số là cố
định tại vì tử số là tổng số lượng
document mà. Nhưng mẫu số mẫu số ở đây
thì
v mẫu số tôi phải đếm xem là có bao
nhiêu document chứa nó được chưa. Thế
thì
cái mẫu số lớn nhất là bằng bao nhiêu
các bạn? Mẫu số mà lớn nhất thì bằng cái
gì?
Mẫu số mà lớn nhất thì bằng cái gì?
Bằng tử số chính xác. Mẫu số kịch kim
đúng không? Mẫu số lớn nhất có thể có là
tử số bằng tử số khi nào? Khi mà cái từ
đấy document nào cũng xuất hiện đúng
không? Cái từ mà document nào cái từ mà
document nào cũng xuất hiện ấy thì
thường cái điểm TF nó rất là cao đúng
không? Doc cái token mà document nào nó
cũng xuất hiện ấy, điểm TF thường nó rất
là cao. Thế nhưng bây giờ nhá về cái IDs
này đúng không? Khi mà tử bằng mẫu thì
phân số bằng 1 đúng không? phân số bằng
1. Logarit cơ số 2 của 1 thì bằng 0.
Đúng chưa? Thấy chưa? Cái cô mà cô đấy
đối xử tốt với các bạn ấy
mà thằng khác thằng nào nó cô ấy đối
cũng cũng đối xử tốt ấy thì cái điểm TF
của cô đấy với thằng nào cũng điểm cũng
cao đúng không? Thằng nào điểm cũng cao
nhưng cái điểm IDF sẽ đánh nó về bằng 0
đúng không? Hai ông nhân với nhau chỉ
cần một ông bằng 0 thôi là cả tích đ
bằng 0 luôn. Được chưa? Một cô gái tốt
là một cô gái mà cô ấy chỉ đối xử đặc
biệt với bạn thôi mà không đối xử đặc
biệt với thằng khác. Được chưa? Còn đối
tượng mà không phải đối tượng không phù
với các bạn là gì? Là cô gái rất là lạnh
lùng với các bạn là thôi rồi đúng không?
Là ông TF = 0 hoặc là gì? Là cô gái đối
xử với bạn rất tốt nhưng mà đối xử thằng
khác cũng thằng nào tốt cả. Thì cái IDF
bằng 0. Đúng chưa? Đấy là cái ý nghĩa
của cái điểm TF IDF này được chưa? Nó
vừa đánh giá cái mức độ xuất hiện thường
xuyên của một từ trong của một token
trong một document trong một loại
document và nó vừa xuất hiện cái nó vừa
đánh giá cái độ hiếm của nó cho các
document khác. Được chưa? Đây là ý nghĩa
của TF IDF. Đây là một cách tính điểm mà
nó rất là phổ biến cho đến tận ngày nay.
Cho tận ngày nay người ta vẫn dùng nó
cực kỳ phổ biến luôn. Được chưa?
Ok.
B nào có câu hỏi gì không?
Em có câu hỏi gì không?
Được nhá. Thì bây giờ
lý thuyết thì chỉ như vậy thôi. Bây giờ
chúng ta sẽ sang phần thực hành. Thực
hành chúng ta sẽ dùng một cái bộ dữ liệu
công ty cũ của mình. Đây bộ dữ liệu mình
làm trong công ty của mình từ hồi 2016
đến 2018. Hồi đấy mình là working
student. Hồi đấy mình chưa tốt nghiệp
mà. H đấy mình là một công ty làm ở Mic.
Công ty này mình làm về mảng HR. Có thể
bây giờ chắc là vẫn còn này.
Vẫn còn đây. Đi ơ cái gì này?
Ơ
thôi không sao đấy. C cho các bạn xem
cái bộ dữ liệu nhá. Bộ rượu nó trông như
này. Mình đã up lên trên Google Drive
rồi nhưng mình muốn chia sẻ các bạn chút
cái a cái cái cách bố dượ này nó được
tạo ra nhá. Ờ
đây các bạn nhìn nhá. Bạn nhìn nhá. Đây
đây là lần đầu trong đời mình đi xin
việc các bạn nhá. Lần đầu trong đời mình
đi xin việc là vào năm 2016 lúc mình đã
25 tuổi rồi. 25 tuổi mình mới đi xin
việc lần đầu. Ngày xưa hồi bách khoa là
hoàn toàn mình không đi không có đi làm
đâu, chỉ có học thôi. Sang bên kia mình
mới bắt đầu mình mới xin được lần đầu.
Job này mình xin vào hồi tháng a cái job
này nó là nó là data nhưng mình viết
nhầm thành data analyst à tháng 23 tháng
9 23 tháng 9. Ờ
cái job này mình cái công ty này là công
ty này về mảng HR về mảng tuyển dụng tức
là họ như cái đấy là họ là chỉ đơn giản
họ là cầu nối giữa người giữa người sinh
và các các công ty thôi. Được chưa? Thế
ờ
thế thì hồi đấy mình appl cái job này
các bạn nhìn hồi CP mình này trắng phớ
chả có cái gì cả.
Đây là mấy cái khoa học online mấy cái
khoa học giống kiểu trên Cera với Udổi
cái cái cái nền tảng này chắc không nổi
tiếng lắm. Đây toàn là một cái practical
code những giống kiểu bài tập lớn trên
trường ấy. Tại vì chả có cái gì để ghi
cả ghi nó vào. Còn cái chỗ này là cái
chỗ mà hồi xưa mình học Bách Khoa. Lúc
mà mình có mình có một cái môn yêu cầu
thc thực tập ấy. Trường yêu cầu thực tập
môn hai tín chỉ mình mình xin vào chỗ
người quen của bố mình nên là chỉ có
đúng hôm đầu đến nhận đền tài với kiểu
hôm cuối đến ký thôi. Chả phải làm cái
gì cả. Nói chung là trắng tình không có
không có một cái gì các bạn nhớ không?
Phải lôi cả lôi cả giải thưởng cấp ba
vào đây này đúng không? Em chả có cái gì
cả. Đấy. Thế hồi đấy người ta cho mình
một cái một cái bài một cái tex một cái
gọi là một cái challenge một cái text
challeng này ta gì? Họ cho mình một cái
bộ dữ liệu như này. Đây là bộ cái rượu
của công ty luôn. Và sau này lúc mình
làm trong suốt 1 năm rưỡ đấy là mình
cũng làm đúng với cái bộ rượu kiểu như
này. Được chưa? Bộ rượu nó như này.
Đây bộ rượu nó trông như thế này.
Đây bố rượu chúng ta có những cộ là
title này, location này, description
này. Được chưa? function này, industry
và color level. Tức là như này, đây là
bộ rượu của các cái job ở Mỹ. The công
ty mình thì bọn mình chủ yếu làm việc ở
châu Âu với cả ở Mỹ. Thế thì
nó có những cái level t này tức là công
ty mình sẽ định nghĩa cái level này thủ
công. Đấy, có những cái level như này
được chưa? Từ từ rất junior đến rất
senior được chưa? rất senior này
à bộ rượu này và họ yêu cầu mình sư một
cái mô hình phân loại làm sao để sau này
tôi đưa một cái input là một cái job có
title location description function
industry môi tôi phải dự đoán xem nó
thuộc cái level nào đấy sa thì họ cho
mình đầu tiên là mình đến phỏng vấn đến
phỏng vấn xong thì họ về nhà họ gửi cho
cái bộ cho cái bài này cho họ bảo là làm
đàm xong thì bảo tao tao cho mày một cái
buổi đến trình bà sau đó mình đến một
mình làm xong khoảng chắc là khoảng tuần
xong mình gửi chị gửi gửi cho họ các thứ
ờ đâu rồi Rồi
đâu rồi?
Đây xong đây là lúc mà upline từ
ô live xong đế đến mùng 7 tháng 11 đây.
Nhà job đây. Lần đầu đời. Đây là lần đầu
tiên trong đời mình đi xin việc. Lần đầu
trong đời viết CV. Lần đầu đi xin việc.
Lần đầu đi appl và lần đầu nhận job.
Mình làm đây xong mình làm được 1 năm
rưỡi. Làm 5 rư xong đến ngày mình ra
trường. Mình ra trường xong thì công ty
nó không offer cho full time luôn. Công
ty nó yêu cầu là vẫn phải làm gọi là gì
nhỉ? vẫn phải làm in nửa năm nữa rồi mới
được xét. Mặc dù mình đã làm ở công ty
5:30 rồi.
Sếp bảo là quy định nó là như thế. Tại
vì mà đúng là những người khác cũng phải
như thế thật. Những người khác cũng phải
như thế. Mình thì mình không muốn thêm
làm làm part time làm intern nữa để mình
nghỉ xong mình lên minin.
Đấy. Thế thì chúng ta sẽ làm về cái bộ
rượu như thế. Cái bộ rượu chúng ta làm
nó sẽ là bộ rượu đấy. Cái bộ mình vừa
mới share các bạn xem ấy. Được chưa? Thì
đây nó sẽ một cái bộ rượu thật. Bộ sự
thật thì nó sẽ tức là nó là một cái
private dataset là cái thứ các bạn sẽ
không các bạn tìm trên mạng đúng không?
Thì trong trong cái khóa này chúng ta sẽ
làm cái bộ này chúng ta thấy được cái sự
khác biệt giữa public với private là gì?
Private thì bao giờ nó dẽ thường nó sẽ
bẩn hơn, nó sẽ có nhiều thứ phải làm
hơn. Còn ví dụ public thì thường là có
người ta clean người ta làm sẵn các thứ
làm làm lông các thứ rồi các bạn làm nó
sẽ nó sẽ dễ dàng hơn. Được chưa? Thì đấy
là về bộ rượu chúng ta. Cái bộ này thì
mình up lên trên Google Drive rồi. Bộ
này trên Google Drive mình đặt tên là
cái gì ấy nhỉ? Bạn chờ mình xem nhá.
Trên Google Drive thì mình đặt tên nó là
hình như là final project thì phải đế
mình nhớ không nhở.
Đâu ấy nhỉ? Class số 20 class số 21 đây.
Đây ta set đây này. Trên của GR nó là
cái bộ đây này. Final project này. Được
chưa? Cái đuôi ODS này. ODS các bạn mở
bằng Excel được nhá. Mở bằng Excel được
nhá. Được chưa?
Ờ thế trước khi vào thì mình muốn hỏi
các bạn một tí này. Ngày xưa ấy hồi mình
appl về công ty này mình bị hỏi câu này
mình hồi đấy mình mình bị hỏi mấy câu
cơ. Có đấy mình bị hỏi một câu là ờ mình
bị hỏi câu là với cả recol khác nhau như
nào?
đấy là mình lúc mình đề này là mình đã
học ở kỳ thứ ba tức là mình mới học hết
năm đầu mình học về AI machining
[khịt mũi] kỳ thứ ba tức bắt đầu năm thứ
hai mình đi hỏi mình hồi đấy mình mình
chưa từng nghe đến hai cái magic này th
mình bảo tao không biết không biết
không yêu cầu nó phải nhiều hơn chứ các
bạn bây giờ bây giờ làm sao như thế này
được bây giờ các bạn có lm rồi ngày xưa
làm gì có gì đâu bây giờ cái c này của
mình xin chắc là 10 tiếp cũng không vào
được công ty thế này mất nhá hỏi các bạn
một tí này bây giờ nhá mình có Mấy cái
level như này ngày xưa mình bị hỏi mấy
câu nhưng mà có một câu mình rất là nhớ
mình muốn hỏi lại các bạn này nhá. Ở
Việt Nam mình thì có những cái trang nào
là tìm việc về
ủ có trang nào tìm việc các bạn nhở?
Mình biết mỗi cái trang IT Việt thôi.
Còn cái trang gì nữa không các bạn nhỉ?
Top CV ừ Linkin là một đúng không? Việt
Nam mình có cái trang init này không
nhở? Init mình thấy ở Đức phổ biến lắm
này. Cực kỳ phổ biến luôn. Không biết ở
Việt Nam có hay dùng cái này không?
Upwork nhá.
Thì các bạn nhìn này, ngày xưa mình bị
một cái ông ông đấy là sếp của mình
nhưng mà cái lúc cái lúc phỏng vấn thì
thì mình chưa vào công ty đúng không?
Sau này ông ấy là sếp là future boss của
mình. Ông đấy hỏi mình một câu là như
này. Ví dụ lên top CV nhỉ? Các bạn bảo
cái gì? Top CV được vào thử top CV nhá.
Top CV này đúng không
các bạn? Nhìn này. Câu hỏi là gì? Khi
chúng ta lên những cái nền tảng như thế
này, chúng ta sẽ rất dễ nhìn thấy những
cái job giống như kiểu là fresh cho
fresher này, cho junior, mid level cũng
có, senior cũng có đúng không? Tậm chí
là team lead manager cũng có cả đủ các
level đúng không? Từ từ thấp đến cao.
Nhưng
gần như chúng ta sẽ không bao giờ nhìn
thấy những cái job thuận cái level chop
bu. Ví dụ như là CEO, CFDER, CTO các bạn
sẽ gần như không bao giờ thấy được những
cái vị trí này.
Gần như sẽ không có, gần như là tuyệt
chủng luôn.
Còn những cái level khác từ junior,
senior đủ cả, thậm chí là senior
developer vẫn có đủ bình thường không
vấn đề gì cả. Bạn nào thấy cho mình lý
do vì sao không bao giờ các bạn tìm được
job kiểu cofounder với cả CEO trên này.
Lý do là vì sao? Mặc dù công ty cũng
phải có nhu cầu đúng không? Công ty phải
nhu cầu làm gì có ông siêu nào làm mãi
được đúng không? Cũng phải thay thế phải
không? C founder họ cũng phải rời đi mà
cũng phải có người mới vào đúng không?
Chúng ta sẽ không bao giờ ta nhìn chóc
trên này. Lý do là vì sao?
Đấy câu ngày dân bị hỏi đấy.
Mình bị hỏi hai lần.
Mình bị mình mình bị hỏi hai lần công ty
này và ngay công ty sau cái công ty đầu
tiên mình làm sau khi dân ra gia ra
trường ấ mình bị hỏi y hiệt cái công ty
kia cũng là công ty là về mảng nhưng mà
lúc ấy mình biết câu trả lời mình mình
trả lời ngon nhưng mà lần đầu mình không
trả lời được dựa vào network để lấy
không hẳn vì những việc đó không phù hợp
với đối tượng tìm trên web này
chưa thuyết phục lắm nhỉ
không mai lên ơ nhưng mà nếu mà mình
muốn tìm người ta công ty mình mình muốn
tìm cứ đăng lên thì làm sao
yêu có không cái gì mà chẳng mô tả được
đúng không anh có 20 năm kinh nghiệm
quản trị, quản lý các thứ, phát triển
cái này, kinh doanh các thứ đúng mô tả
được mà.
À đúng rồi đúng rồi, chính xác
đúng không? Chúng ta mà để đối thủ mà để
các cái investor mà biết rằng công ty
đang tìm kiếm những cái vị trí chó bu
như này ấy, kể cả dù lý do là do ông đấy
nghỉ hưu, tức là lý do bình thường đúng
không? Nhưng mà đối thủ hoặc là hoặc là
investor mà nhìn thông tin này là công
ty bạn sẽ gặp cho vù ngay đúng không?
Nên là người ta sẽ phải có những cái
luồng khác t ví dụ người ta sẽ liên lạc
với các cái external requer người ta
những cái requer mà kiểu thân quen ờ
đáng tin cậy ấy người ta sẽ nhờ tìm chứ
người ta sẽ không cần ta bắp lên đây
đúng không? Tại vì để lên đây là đúng
rồi là để đúng ai nhìn vào mà thấy công
ty đang đi tìm CEO người ta sẽ biết ngay
công ty đang bất ổn đúng không? Tìm mẫu
ông de thì chả vấn đề gì cả nhưng mà tìm
CO là có vấn đề rồi đúng không? Ừ ok.
Chính xác là như thế
rồi. Thế nhá. Ờ
rồi. Ok. Và code đi. Code đi. Bộ rượu
như thế này.
Ờ
rồi nhá. Bộ rượu thì trên Google Drive
rồi đây. Mình sẽ gửi lại bạn trên Zalo
các bạn đỡ phải các bạn đỡ phải đi tìm
nhá.
Này xuống này bạn. Chờ tí mình à đâu ấy
nhỉ?
Mình gửi trên a đây nhá. Vâ mình gửi
mình mình gửi mình gửi trên Zalo nhá.
F check này các bạn đỡ phải đi tìm. Được
chưa? Thế thì bây giờ mình sẽ chở tí
file này nó nặng khoảng 10 m 10 m nhá.
Được chưa? Thì bây giờ mình sẽ
mình sẽ tạo một cái script mới như này.
SP mới này nhá. Đúng không? Mình sẽ gọi
này ví dụ đây là à document không ghi là
jobification
được chưa? Chop classification như thế
này. Được chưa? Thì bây giờ cái file này
ấy mà các bạn mở
các bạn mở bằng
Excel thì cũng được thôi. Đây Excel nhá.
Đây final project nhá. Mở bằng Excel
này.
Đây chó như này được chưa?
Thế này
đây đúng không âm có title này, location
này
được chưa? Function này, industry này,
col level được chưa? Level như này. Thế
thì đúng không? Đợi nhụ đơn giản thôi.
Dựa vào năm cột đầu để dự đoán cột cuối.
Thật ra cái bài này với các bạn đem về
năm 2026 mà làm thì bây giờ quá là nhanh
đúng không các bạn? vứt vào cũng xong
đúng không? Bây giờ cái này bày nó có tỉ
cách để làm mà cái cách đây 10 năm thì h
đấy nó hạn chế đấy deing nó còn chưa
phát triển lắm bản thân deing cũng chưa
phát triển m người ta vẫn còn dùng mấy
cái mình cổ cổ hồi đấy transformer còn
chưa ra đời cơ mà đấy lúc đấy bọ ngày
xưa nó sẽ chen hơn được chưa bộ rượu nó
nó như này
bây giờ đây là mình mở đây thôi mình
cũng có thể mình sẽ mở trong a mở trong
này thì nhìn nó sẽ hơi khó đúng không
mình sẽ mở trong a
trong trong trong bonth này được chưa
bây gi
tôi sẽ tôi sẽ mở đây đúng không ạ?
Import p
s thì đi được chưa? Data bằng pandas ch
read csv này đúng không? File là file
này cũng chả phải file Excel đâu nhưng
mà các bạn các bạn đọc bằng read Excel
các bạn nó không phải là file CSV các
bạn đọc R CV cũng được các bạn đọc bằng
read Excel đúng không mọi bài trước mình
dùng R CV nhiều rồi nên mình dùng read
Excel đi Excel nhá được chưa Excel này
sau các bạn cho vào cái tên của nó này
project.
DS nhá. Được chưa? Mở này nó sẽ hơi lâu
một tí. Mở nhá.
Ờ bôi đen này. Click chuột phải này.
Chọn execute sẽ chuyển màn thành console
nhá. Được chưa?
hơi lâu một tí tại vì cái bộ đây các bạn
nhìn nhá data đây được chưa nó có hơn
8000 hàng cơ 8000 hàng 8040 74 hàng các
bạn cho mình xin phép tí mình đóng cửa
cho mưa to
chờ mình một tí nhá
Có bạn nào nhà đang ở Hà Nội nhở? Mưa to
các bạn nhỉ
nhá. Dữ liệu này đúng không? Có 8000
hàng có tám cột đúng không? Mở qua một
tí nhá. Đây bộ rượu trông như này nhá.
Rượu trông như này được chưa?
8000 hàng đây. Hơn 8000 80774 nó từ 0 mà
đúng không? Cột như thế này. Đấy thì bây
giờ chúng ta nói là bài toán phân loại
thôi. Nó bài toán phân loại. Lấy cái cột
cuối là cột tit và năm cột đầu là cột ờ
năm cột đầu là feature đúng không? Đấy,
bộ rượu trông như này bây gi nó lớn hơn
thôi. Hai cái bộ trước cái bộ cái bộ DBT
nó khoảng 700 sle cái bộ cái bộ điểm thì
1000 bộ này nó có hơn 8000 đúng không?
Và dữ liệu đây là văn bản chứ nó không
còn là dữ liệu feature đơn giản như kia
nữa. Được chưa? Bây giờ chúng ta sẽ cùng
nhau chúng ta xử lý. Thì bây giờ ờ với
cái bộ như này ấy thì mình sẽ không dùng
cái thư viện data profiling để mình chế
quân hóa để mình gen ra cái report.
Với cái dựa kiểu này mình sẽ không dùng
cái thư viện data profiling mình gen
report. Có bạn nào biết là lý do là vì
sao không? Vì sao mình lại không dùng
cái thư viện kia kia nữa? Cái thư viện
data profiling này mọi khi mình dùng
này. Đây đây này. Cái thư viện mọi khi
mình vẫn dùng này. Đấy mọi khi mình tạo
ra report đúng không? Đây hai cái report
này. Đấy đây hai report này. Nhưng bài
này mình sẽ không dùng. Không phải vì
lớn không phải vì lớn quá không phải lớn
thì lại càng cần phải dùng. Nhưng mà bài
này
thì không nên dùng. Tại vì sao?
Tại vì sao các bạn?
Ừ đúng rồi. Tại vì nó toàn là tex chính
xác đúng không? Coration thì cũng không
hẳn. Tức là nếu mà nó là dạng
categorical thì các bạn vẫn có thể các
bạn thống kê một về cái phân bố của nó
thì cũng được nhưng mà vấn đề nó toàn là
text đúng không? Chủ yếu nó toàn là
text. Tex thì chả có gì để tính cả đúng
không? Các bạn cứ thử nghĩ và xem đây
nhá. Mở lại cái bộ đằng trước này đúng
không? Dữ liệu mà không phải số mà nó là
dạng cical thì vẫn thì vẫn chơi được.
Đây này. Đây cái report lằn trước đây
nhá. Cái bộ student score đây đúng
không? Nếu mà nó là nếu mà nó nó mà là
số nó mà là nó mà là gender đây categor
tôi vẫn thống kê được đúng không? Đây
thống kê được này đúng không? Phân bố
của nó đúng không? Số thì vẫn dùng
histogram được nhưng mà cái bộ này nó là
tex đúng không? Thì bây giờ gen thì cũng
gen được thôi nhưng mà thực ra cũng chả
có cái gì để các bạn nhìn vào cả. Gen
thì th ra nó cũng chả có cái gì để nhìn
đúng không? Thế thôi mình sẽ không cần
phải ấy nữa. Nếu có làm cái gì đấy mình
chỉ xem ví dụ là cái phân bố của cái
target thôi. Cái tagit của chúng ta cái
col level này. Đ mình thử in in ra nhá.
print này, data này cơ level chư c level
level chấm value
này. Được chưa? Nhìn nhá.
Mình muốn xem cái phân bố của cái class
nào.
Đây các bạn nhìn này.
Các bạn th thấy sao các bạn?
Các bạn thấy sao?
Các
bạn đây thấy sao?
Các bạn thấy sao? Lệch quá đúng không?
Đấy, dựa thật sau này nó toàn như này
đấy. Dự thật nó sẽ không giống cái bộ
diabet đâu. Cái bộ diabet là cái rượu mà
nó còn khá cân bằng đúng không? Dữ thật
là như này này. Đúng không các bạn? Nhìn
này. Có một cái level nó bị sai tên. Cái
từ này nó là từ tiếng Đức. Ver tức là
leader. Đây cái từ này nhá. Từ này thì à
đây cái từ này hồi chưa cái bài bài giải
thích đây
và đấy mình hỏi người ta đây thì nó
người ta cho nó tương đương này thật ra
nó cũng tể dịch ra nó cũng không hẳn như
này mà thôi người ta bảo thế thì đấy
đúng không đấy hồi đấy mình cũng hỏi
người ta là ví dụ mất cân bằng quá thì
làm thế nào bây giờ thì người ta bảo
đúng là nó cân bằng thật nhưng mà
nhưng mà người ta muốn làm thế để người
ta xem mình xử lý như
Được chưa?
Rồi. Thế bây giờ mình biết đúng không?
Biết nó lệch rồi. Tí nữa chúng ta phải
để ý cái này đúng không? Lệch đúng
không? Thông thường những cái level thấp
thì các bạn sẽ có nhiều data, level thứ
hai cao các bạn có ít data thế thôi.
Được chưa? Thế thế bây giờ tiếp nhá.
Tiếp nhá. Thế bây giờ mình làm gì bây
giờ các bạn nhở? Bây giờ chúng ta làm
cái gì bây giờ?
Không kê được, không trực quân hóa được
thì bây giờ
không tiền gì chưa?
gì sử thế
làm gì bây giờ?
Ừ chọn tit đúng không? Mà tách nó ra tit
chọn cột là cột cứ ở level rồi đúng
không? Tit đây.
Được chưa? Copy nhanh nhá. Trên split
đâu rồi?
split này cho sang resarch đi tĩa kiểu
gì chả dùng đúng không
một này
đây
được chưa spit này bây giờ mình thử nhá
bây giẽ thử in ra cái
mình sẽ in ra lại cái in lại cái
distribution nhá ví dụ này print này
i ch value count how
được chưa một Cái này mình sẽ in ra cái
ở dưới nữa. Mình sẽ in ra ở đây là
value count.
Erain value count này.
In cái dấu phân cách nữa.
Được chưa? Mình sẽ in ra cái phân bố cái
distribution của các cái label lúc trước
và lúc sau khi mình split nhá.
Chờ một tí bạn nhá. Chạy hơi lâu một tí
nhá.
Nỗi gì đây
hả?
Cer level mình biết sai cái gì à?
À dấu gạch level
đây cứ level như này được chưa? Bây giờ
thì ok rồi.
Em thử nhá.
Rồi các bạn nhìn nhá.
Các bạn nhìn này. Đây là rượu lúc ban
đầu đúng không? Rượu chúng ta tách ra
đúng không?
Thì các bạn à
thì các bạn nhìn nhá. Bây giờ ấy tổng dụ
sle nó như này đúng không?
Ví dụ đi cái cách này nó là 70 đúng
không? 70 thì nếu ấy bình thường ấy tức
là chúng ta chúng ta phân chia tỉ lệ là
80 20 đúng không? Đây này. Test size là
2072 là 20 đúng không? Thì chúng ta phân
tỉ lệ 8020 ấy thì tổng số lượng sample
nó sẽ rơi vào 80% vào bộ trin và 20% là
vào bộ test đúng không? Thế thế nhưng mà
ở đây các bạn để ý một cái điều là gì?
Là cái tỉ lệ 8020 này ấy nó chỉ được đảm
bảo cho tổng dữ liệu thôi. Tổng công này
là 80 tổng này là 20 chứ nó không được
đảm bảo cho từng class một. Ví dụ này
cái class này nó là 70 ấy thì đáng nhẽ
ra nếu 70 mà chia đẹp ra là 80 20 ấy thì
nó sẽ phải là 5 6 14 đúng không? Nếu nó
chia đẹp nó sẽ phải là 5 6 14 tức là gì?
Tức là ông trên phải là 56 ông kia phải
14. Như đây là ông này 58 rồi thì ông
kia chỉ có 12 thôi. Được chưa? Ông này
chia thì ok 30 thì chia là 24 ế nhưng mà
các bạn nhìn này. Ông này là 4. 4 thì nó
không chia cho 5 nhưng mà đáng nhẽ nó
chia để gần nhất ấy thì phải là 3 trên 1
test đúng không? 3 thì vào trên 1 thì
vào test đúng không? Thế nhưng mà nó
không đảm bảo. Các bạn có nhớ là hôm
chúng ta nói về chúng ta học về khi
chúng ta nói về chia dữ liệu đỉnh bộ
trên bộ vai bộ test ấy mình nói là gì?
Là nó cũng giống như con người thôi.
Chúng ta bình thường chúng ta ôn thi ý
cái dạng bài nào các bạn hay thi các bạn
sẽ ôn nhiều ra là các bạn ít ít câu hỏi
các bạn sẽ ôn ít đúng không? Thì ở đây
cũng phải giống giống nh như vậy. Tức là
gì? Cái gì mà mô hình nó hay gặp ấy thì
chúng ta phải cho nó luyện tập nhiều.
Cái gì môn nó ít gặp chúng ta phải cho
nó ít đúng không? Chúng ta nên làm sao
để cho cái tỉ lệ này nó nó nó bằng nhau
thì nó sẽ là đẹp nhất đúng không? Làm
nay chúng ta sẽ không làm được cái điều
đấy. Được chưa?
Thế thì thế thì bây giờ chúng ta muốn
làm vậy thì cho làm nào thì bây gi chúng
ta sẽ sử dụng thêm một cái tham số nữa
tên là stratify. Stratify ở đây được
chưa? Strafi
bằng I và đây thì điều gì? Tức là tôi sẽ
phân chia cái tỉ lệ này đều cho từng cho
theo từng cái class trong cái i này. Thì
khi các bạn phân chia vậy nó sẽ rất là
đều các bạn nhìn nhá. Tất nhiên nó sẽ
đảm bảo gì là cái tỉ lệ 802 này nó sẽ
đảm bảo cho từng class luôn chứ không
phải là chỉ có tổng.
Đây các bạn nhìn thấy chưa? Này này 4
này. 3 rơi vào đây này đúng không? 70
rơi vào 56 này. 30 24 này. Đẹp chưa? Đẹp
chưa? Ngon lành chưa? Statify lần trước
với cái bộ job ý ờ cái lần trước với cái
bộ diabet ấ mình không dùng. Tại vì sao?
Tại vì nó không lệch lắm. Bởi nó lệch ít
thì cũng không cần lắm. Còn bộ này nó
rất là lệch thì mình nên sử dụng này để
đảm bảo là gì? Là cái distribution, cái
phân bố của các cái class trong bộ
chuyên và bộ test là tương đương nhau.
Được chưa?
Rồi đến đây có ai có câu hỏi gì không?
Nay có ai có câu hỏi gì không?
Này cũng chưa có gì lạ đúng không? Chưa
có gì lạ cả đúng không? Mọi thứ nó vẫn
ngoài cái shorttify thì cũng không có gì
cả.
Mình chưa nói
sự xong rồi đã đ tạm thời chúng ta chưa
nói gì về về balance data vội đúng không
xong rồi chạy ok rồi mình sẽ nói thử
mình sẽ nói về cái đoạn balance data xem
làm như thế nào nhá xe có nhưng mà đ
balan chắc phải vào buổi sau nhá sau xây
dựng xong mình sẽ nói phần đấy nhá chúng
ta có cách để chúng ta có thể balance
data chúng ta over và under chúng ta sẽ
kiểm chúng ta sẽ control cái tỉ lệ của
nó muốn bao nhiêu là tùy chúng ta nhá
các bạn nhìn này bây gi nói tiếp nhá nói
tiếp này thì bây giờ chúng ta sẽ nói qua
một chút về chúng ta sẽ nói qua một chút
về cái việc là chúng ta sẽ xử lý chỗ này
như thế nào đi. Được chưa? Nói v một tí
đi. Ờ thế v các bạn các bạn nhìn này.
Bây giờ cái input nó có năm cột đúng
không? Title, location, description,
function, industry. Hay nói qua một tí
đi. Chúng ta sẽ xử lý chúng như nào
để nguyên này đưa vào mô hình nó không
có hiểu đúng không? Nó phải tiền xử lý.
Nào các bạn nói qua một chút này. Cái
cột title, cột title này nếu tiền xử lý
theo các bạn chúng ta sẽ tiền xử lý như
thế nào bây giờ?
Xử lý như thế nào thì phù hợp?
Title tiền xử lý như thế nào thì phù
hợp?
Vectoriz chung chung quá. Ừ, tất nhiên
phải vector rồi. Tất cả chúng nó đều
phải vector. Nhưng mà vector bằng cách
nào bây giờ?
Số hóa, vectơ hóa đúng rồi. Nhưng mà
bằng cách nào bây giờ?
Nghĩa nào bây giờ?
Không.
Chính xác. Đấy. Cái mà nói đúng rồi đấy.
Dùng dùng má thì hơi chung chung quá
đúng không? Mình sẽ dùng cái gì? Cụ thể
là mình dùng cái gì? Cụ thể là mình dùng
cái gì? Dùng Magic làm sao để làm sao để
biến nó thành magic bây giờ? Làm sao
biến nó thành magic bây giờ?
Làm nào bây giờ?
Word thì à
chính xác hơn một tí là chúng ta dùng TF
IDF đúng không? Vừa mới học xong đúng
không? TF IDF đúng không? TFIDF là xử lý
được ngay. Được chưa? Cho chúng ta dùng
TF IDF
dùng thử luôn nhá. Dùng thử luôn nhá.
Nói đến đâu làm luôn đúng không? TFDS
thử nhá. Thì bây giờ c title này đúng
không? Bây giờ chúng ta dùng TFDS thì
đây
trong sơn á cái lon nó có đây nó có là
IDF vectorizer đây nhá. Dùng rất là dễ
luôn. Tất cả các cái class trong Sơn
dùng rất là dễ. Tidf này nhá. Sec
learn.fefaturection.text
này. Tidf này. Được chưa các bạn? cũng
khởi tạo cũng fit transform với bộ truyề
trong bộ test không khác gì lúc chúng ta
làm việc với các cái liệu cơ bản thông
thường đúng không mình dùng thử nhá đây
import chỗ này này
làm thử xem luôn
đây
à gì vectorizer
được chưa dùng cái này mìnhẽ dùng là
à chết à chưa import nhỉ form
TF đi vizer này được chưa? Bây giờ chúng
ta vectorizer nhá. Đúng không? E TF rồi
PFER này. Được chưa? Sau mình sẽ fit
transform mình sẽ fit transform sao có
cái cao này ở đây nhỉ? Mình sẽ fit
transform với bộ với bộ train nhá đúng
không? À vậy mình chỉ title thôi. Ví dụ
đây nhá. Output đúng không? Bằng
vectorizer form không phải xin chỉ mỗi
title thôi. Title nhá. Mình sẽ in ra cái
output này. In
output chấm
output thôi. Thử này
nó sẽ hơi lâu một tí các bạn nhá. Tại vì
mình nhiều nhiều tài liệu mà hơi lâu một
tí.
Các bạn nhìn nó có một cái lỗi này. Có
một cái lỗi là gì? Là a
tại sao nên dùng? Tại vì là tại vì là nó
là cái option phù hợp nhất đúng không?
Tại sao nên dùng th trường hợp này cho
cô title? Tại vì là nó là phù hợp nhất.
Các bạn thử nghĩ xem làm gì có cái gì
phù hợp hơn đâu đúng không? Không dùng
tfid thì dùng cái gì bây giờ đúng không?
nó là phù hợp nhất trong những cái thứ
chúng ta đã học. TF và DF cho cột này là
phù hợp nhất. Các bạn thử nghĩ xem là
dùng cái gì bây giờ? Dùng cái gì cho cột
này bây giờ ngoài TF IDF đúng không các
bạn? Nh nó có một cái lỗi này. À có một
cái điều nữa quên mất có một cái điều
nữa mình trước khi cái lỗi này nhá các
bạn nhá. Cái lỗi này nó là gì? In object
hp lower. Nó có một cái chỗ này các bạn
nhìn cái đoạn code nó này. Nó có một chỗ
doc. lower này. Cái lỗi này th được điều
gì các bạn? In object has no hard
attribute lower. Nó thệt điều gì đây?
Lỗi này là lỗi gì?
Giữ đựng dặp in không có.
>> À đúng rồi. Chính chính xác. Chính xác.
Đúng rồi. Đúng không? Ờ đúng không? Ví
dụ đây các bạn nhìn nhá.
Ví dụ bình thường nh các bạn có cái từ
là data bằng tr đây đúng không? Chúng ta
print data. Lower thế này đúng không?
Thì ok đúng không? Lower thế này đúng
không? Lower ch đưa về dạng thường này
ok đúng không? Nó là thành chữ viết
thường đúng không? Nó là số 5 chẳng hạn
thì vẫn đưa về viết thường được. Đưa
viết thường được nhưng mà nếu là số 5
như đây là kiểu thì vẫn còn được. Đây là
kiểu số 5 này không được. Đây lỗi đây nó
đúng cái lỗi này. Được chưa? Th sửa lỗi
này có nhiều cách nhưng mà cái cách mà
dễ nhất ấy, cách dễ nhất thì chúng ta
lúc chúng ta đọc dữ liệu bài này chúng
ta chỉ luôn là deti bằng str này tức là
gì? Tất cả cột tôi đều là kiểu string
thì nó sẽ không bị lỗi nữa. Được chưa?
Chạy từ này.
Được chưa? Ngay từ đầu tôi định nghĩa
luôn là tất cả đều là string đúng không?
Số má thì cũng đưa vào đây hết thì cũng
đưa thành string hết. Được chưa? Làm như
này
chờ tí xem có lỗi gì nữa nhá.
Rồi ok. Đây này. Đây các bạn nhìn này.
Nó thành đây cái kiểu giống như kiểu on
hô nọ mình mình nhìn đấy đúng không? Nó
sẽ kêu ghi kiểu này cho nó chỉ ghi cái
phần tử nó khác không thôi. Được chưa
các bạn? Chú ý này. Có một cái nữa mình
quên mình quên mình chưa làm nó gì mình
phải thống kê xem là có cái ô nào nó bị
khuyết hay không đúng không? Mình chưa
có làm cái điều đấy đúng không? Chỗ trên
mình chưa có làm, mình chưa kiểm tra xem
rượu có bị khuyết hay không đúng không?
Muốn kiểm tra thì bình thường chúng ta
sẽ nhìn vào cái report nhưng mà ở đây
chúng ta không có report nữa rồi. Chúng
ta sẽ có thể ch kiểm ra thủ công chúng
ta làm như này. R này data.
Info này. Info này nó cho bạn biết xem
các bạn có bị khuyết cái gì không nhá.
Bình thường có cái có cái report chúng
ta generate ra thì chúng ta dùng report
luôn. Nhưng mà đây không có chúng ta
dùng hàm. Chính rất là phương thức đúng
không? Method thì chính xác hơn.
Nào nhìn một tí nhá.
Các bạn thấy sao?
Các bạn thấy sao các bạn?
Có 1 đúng không? Chính xác có 1 có 1 ô
bị này. Được chưa? Nào trong trường hợp
này đúng không? Tức là trong cái cột
description này có một có một ô nó bị
khuyết đúng không?
Nó làm thế nào bây giờ? Theo bạn chúng
ta làm nào bây giờ?
Theo bạn chúng ta làm nào bây giờ?
Làm nào về cái ô bị khuyết này bây giờ?
Đúng là bình thường chúng ta có thể
impute đúng không? Có thể chúng ta có
thể imp chứ không phải email. Email là
thay đổi biến đổi rồi đúng không? Cái
đơn giản là chúng ta xóa. Thì vì sao vì
sao chúng ta lại xóa các bạn nhở? Tại vì
nó nó làm sao nó ít đúng không? Nó ít.
Thật ra ấy nếu mà nói gọi là kỹ tính hơn
một chút ấy trước khi chúng ta xóa chúng
ta phải xem các thứ. Đúng là bài này
chúng ta chỉ có một hàng bị khuyết thôi.
Chúng ta có thể xóa luôn. Nhưng mà nếu
mà nói kỹ tính ấy thì trước khi xóa
chúng ta vẫn phải kiểm tra một thứ nữa
các bạn. Các bạn biết là phải kiểm tra
cái thứ gì không?
Cái thứ là là là cái hàng này ấy nó
thuộc về cái job driver nào? Nhỡ đâu nó
thuộc về cái job driver đã có ít sample
rồi đúng không? Đúng rồi. Đúng rồi.
Chẳng may giờ thiểu số đúng không? Nếu
mà kỹ tính ra là như vậy nhưng mà nhưng
mà chắc là cũng không đen đến thế đâu
nhỉ? Đúng không? Xóa xong mình xóa xong
mình thử xem cái distribution là biết mà
đúng không? Xem là mấy cái ông thiểu số
còn bị không. Nhưng mà chắc khả năng cao
không đến mức đen đến mức đấy đâu đúng
không? Ừ đúng không? Xóa đúng xóa xóa
thì dễ lắm. Xóa thì thô chúng ta trong
trong trong pandas nó có một cái hàm gọi
là hàm drop nan. Drop nan thì drop nan
này các bạn sẽ giúp các bạn có thể xóa
những cái ô viện khuyết thôi. Đây nhá.
Đúng đối đầu là 8074 đúng không? Thì bây
giờ mình nhìn nhá. Bây giờ mình sẽ mình
sẽ xóa bớt cái ô bị khuyết đi đúng
không? Data
bằng data bằng cái gì nhở?
CH.Da.
Nan đây nan mình phải chia ra cái trục
của nó.
Assis bằng 0. Xóa theo hàng đúng không?
Xóa theo hàng. Chạy lại thử nhá. Chạy
lại thử không? Đây là 8074 đúng không?
Để xem còn bao nhiêu nhá.
Ơ
mình xóa mất rồi.
chưa
đấy. Xong cho xong cho tiền xử lý ở dưới
này đúng không? Tiền xử lý bật lại phát
nà. Đây đẹp rồi đúng không? Đẹp rồi. Có
vẻ đẹp rồi đấy. Đúng không? Đây không có
nào bị khuyết nữa. Được chưa? Mình in
lại cái output nhá. Cái output bạn nhớ
là gì? Thì cái output này nó sẽ dưới cái
dạng là nó sẽ chỉ in ra cái phần tử nó
khác không thôi đúng không? Chứ nó không
in ra cả cái ma trận. Cái ma trận nó
nhiều phần tử lắm đúng không? Mình sẽ in
ra cái output chấm chấm shap nhá. Shap
các bạn nhìn này. Shap này
chên lại nhá. Chên lại này là cái shap
này nhá.
Nó sẽ một cái ma trận rất là lớn. Mặt
trận này nó có số hàng chúng ta sẽ bằng
số lượng sample của bộ train và số cột
là bằng số lượng số lượng token được tạo
ra từ cái title này. Được chưa?
Hàng chắc là khoảng 6000 mấy đấy đúng
không?
Hàng đây này 600 này đúng không? Cột là
3013 chưa? Cái trận rất là lớn nhận rất
là lớn đúng không? Đây mới chỉ cột title
thôi. Title là cột nó còn nó còn bé đúng
không? Sau cho xử lý đến cột description
nó còn dài nữa. Được chưa?
Rồi các bạn đến đây có ai có câu hỏi gì
không
các bạn nhá? Bài tập về nhà. Hôm nay
chúng ta mới thử sử cột title.
Các bạn thử áp dụng những cái gì chúng
ta học trong buổi hôm nay và những gì
chúng ta thư hành hai buổi trước rồi.
Các bạn thử tự mình phát triển tiếp cái
script này nhá. Buổi sau chúng ta sẽ làm
nhưng mà các bạn thử về các bạn tự làm
nếu mà không có mình hướng dẫn. Được
chưa? Các bạn làm như nào các bạn có thể
các bạn các bạn có thể dùng chat để các
bạn tìm kiếm thông tin chứ các bạn đừng
có bảo nó code cho các bạn luôn nhá. Tìm
thông tin tức là gì? Ví dụ tôi muốn làm
này làm này tôi làm thế nào đúng không?
Chứ các bạn đừng có bảo luôn là tôi có
một cái bộ dữ này code cho tôi được chưa
nhá. Cố mình tự code được chưa? Buổi sau
chúng ta sẽ thử làm xem. Cái bài nó sẽ
có nhiều cách giải. Cách các bạn cách
mình có thể khác nhau không vấn đề gì.
Miễn là chúng ta đều giải quyết được bài
toán là sau. Được chưa nhá. T chúng ta
lại học bình thường. Tiếp chúng ta tuần
sau chúng ta sẽ học cái buổi thứ bảy
chúng ta sẽ xử lý tiếp cái này được
chưa? Sau chúng ta sẽ học tiếp xong bài
toán time series forecasting. Được chưa?
Bài toán dự đoán chu chỗa thời gian nhá.
Ok mình sẽ cho các bạn record luôn và
mình sẽ up cho các bạn cái script đang
rang dở này nhá.
Ok.
Bạn có câu hỏi gì không?
Thế nhá. Chúc các bạn ăn tối ngon miệng.
Chúc các bạn buổi tối vui vẻ nhá. Bye
mọi người nha. Bye mọi người nha.
By mọi người nha.